Hello everybody, hello, hello!
Welcome to Hatsune Miku Colorful Stage!
Yay!
Hello everybody, sorry for being a little late.
My new shiny iPad that I bought for, oh it's the music bit
too loud, sorry, let me...
Sorry, it is a music game.
Okay, let me turn the music down a little bit.
We have one sound guy here, but they're only here for 10
minutes, so let's hope we get all this sorted out within
that 10 minutes.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Huge shout out and thank you to Sega and Hatsune Miku
Colorful Stage for today's sponsor.
Oh, my gosh.
For those who don't know, the last time, also, the BGM is a
little better now, guys.
It's a bit better, guys.
Let me know.
Uh, let me, before I begin, I can turn it down a little bit
more before I start.
It's still tad loud.
Okay, I'll turn it down a little bit more.
I need to turn it up for me, because I need to listen to
music when I play.
It is a rhythm game.
Um, so, oh my gosh, I lost my train of thought.
Um, but, uh, the last time, uh, the last time I played
Hatsune Miku, colorful stage, when the game first came out.
I was also sponsored too.
We're there for this year and out.
It is their 4.5 year anniversary for the global version.
So today's a very special day.
There's a lot of new things today to check out.
Okay, BGM is good.
Probably brought up during gameplay a bit.
Okay, so I'll need to...
I'll bring it up just a little bit.
So yes, happy birthday, Hatsune Miku.
a colorful stage hello yay but it's not gonna be a little
late guys um steam wasn't booting up for some reason it was
like forever buffering so i just figured that out and then
also and then also i was trying to figure out how to
transfer my the other account well to the new ipad account
um because i didn't realize i didn't realize i'm so stupid
um that accounts don't transfer over account, you have to
link it to your game center.
And I was like, how do I do this?
So that's like, I'm like a grandma.
You're like, grandma, that's how you take a photo of your
phone.
I think I don't understand.
But thank you.
Yeah, I was just like, where do I, I don't, because they
have to do it in the main menu to transfer the account.
I was just like, I know where is the transfer I linked it
how do I but I figured it out guys I figured it out I am
still jet lag I will have to say don't click on the random
links grandma but but they says that but they said that I'll
save a prince though if I click it
so um anyway so I'm still jet lagged I did I I I'm I have
tattooed hours of sleep because I'm still fighting jet lag.
That's okay.
I got coffee, guys.
Anyway, don't worry.
The coffee will enhance my rhythm.
I believe.
So anyway, there is a lot of special events for today
because, like I said, it is colorful stages.
Had to say a week in colorful stages.
4.5 year anniversary.
So there's a lot of stuff to look forward to.
As you guys can see, Gotcha.
One time only comes with 4.5 year anniversary exclusive
costume.
I mean, I could just do that right now.
Give me a sec.
Well, I will do that when I download the data.
Oh, wait.
It's already downloaded.
That was fast.
I was a little worried here.
So I believe this is the one I have to pull.
We'll just do it.
Okay, before I do pull it.
for there is a lot of stuff so for those who don't know
there is a new Porter Robinson collab song so the Porter
Robinson costume for the virtual avatar in my Sakai and
there's like I said there's double rates for four star
gotcha 4.5 anniversary set bundles in store and there is a
UGC campaign on socials right now I think I pull it all of
this up I'm gonna for anticipation um I'm just gonna let me
show you guys all the other stuff so new login bonus that
that let me download all of this and show you guys before I
do the pull um as you guys know I'm so good at rhythm games
as you all know I'm very well known for my rhythm it's gonna
be all right so the mule of porter robinson's song called
cheerleader uh so there's that some of the 4.5 year
anniversary stuff that they have released there is the new
login bonus item look at that look at that cute little
avatar that you have it's like a little apparently it's like
they added a little there's so many new things since the
last time played which was 4.5 years ago um there's so guys
it's crazy all these new things that they added since I last
played.
It's insane.
would have thought so much content.
We've been 4.5 years.
What a thought.
Anyway, this is also celebrating the, there is also a login
campaign.
I know in such a short amount of time too.
It's like the game quadrupled in like gameplay.
within 4.5 years.
Oh my god, you should get on right now.
Everything is so new.
So, there is a login bonus and we all love free stuff.
So, you can receive 3,000 crystals plus a 4.5 year
anniversary free gotcha ticket.
And it lasts all the way till the end of 30th.
So, you have almost a month to capitalize on the free stuff
and we all love free stuff.
Yippee!
And then finally...
Oh wait, no, that's not finally.
Fine here.
There is...
So there's double drop rates.
So drop rates are increased for exclusive characters and
characters of your choice.
And there's...
You can have eight characters in total.
So you have a better chance to pull the favorite character
of your choice.
And there is one more thing.
Let me download this real quick.
Thank you guys, thank you all for the subs, the vitties,
guys.
I'll read them all after the sponsor portion, but thank you
guys so much.
I really, really appreciate it.
And I'm downloading the final image of the campaign that
they have.
But I already downloaded it.
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
And there is a special Nendroid giveaway.
So you follow their page and share their post for a chance
to receive a...
School Sakai Miku Nendroid!
Yippee!
More free stuff!
Yay!
So these are all the free things that they're doing.
A lot of the events that they're doing for the 4.5 year
anniversary.
So yeah, look for it.
I mean, you can hop on in right now.
I will be... I've never played the multiplayer before
because I know it's crazy.
But 4.5 years ago, it didn't really have the multiplayer
function.
So I think it's new.
But you can, if you want to support this stream and support
the game, please feel free to click on the link pinned in
chat or use exclamation point Miku or Miku or yeah, and
click on the link and you can download the game right now
and play with me guys.
I gotta take, I'm sorry, I need to, I need to, I need to
chug down this coffee.
my rhythm later.
I was just like, I gotta check this coffee down real quick.
Before I fight you guys, I need my coffee buff.
It's like, I, oh my God.
Guys, I don't think, guys, I don't know if it's gonna look
pretty.
I fight you guys.
Is there a teamwork in this multiplayer or is this a pvp i
gotta before we before we fight each other is a pvp or is a
pvp you're a game you're right every oh it's teamwork all
right all right all right you're gonna have i'll care don't
worry guys we all know that i'll carry you guys because i am
very well known for
Okay, I believe this is the premium gift gotcha.
So we have a one-time poll for this.
So I'm going to click it now.
So it comes, I can get any of these.
So it comes with a 4.5-year anniversary exclusive costumes.
And, all right, I'm going to pull it.
I'm going to do it.
No.
Oh, I'm gonna do it.
Oh, oh, my God, I'm gonna pull it, guys.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, my God, the coffee is actually hitting me right now.
It actually is hitting me.
Whoa, just pull it.
It's like, oh, my God, guys, I'm gonna do it, guys.
I swear, remember to hit that follow-up button before I do
it.
Guys, you're, remember to click on the link, guys.
I'm gonna do it now.
Any second now.
Yeah, I have to zoom these right now.
Oh, wow.
She's gonna...
In 10 seconds, I'm gonna do a countdown, guys.
In 10 seconds, I'm gonna do it.
Just give me...
Just...
If you guys said 5-50s, remember here?
I said 5-50s on Twitch.
I will do it.
I'll pull.
I'll do the pull.
Do it, cow.
Whoa, 10, 9.
8, 7, and 6 Oh, guys, oh, I didn't think about Twitch Prime
If you do a Twitch Prime I'm gonna do it, I'll pull it
Another Twitch Prime, I'm gonna pull it Right now Please,
stop Stop Oh, yeah, I'll pull it, I'll pull it, yeah I'll
pull it, I'll pull it for real
Toki, please Toki, please all right tap to start the
suspense is killing me mike thank you for gifting a dear one
sub you're about to piss me off right now oh i'm gonna tap
it guys i'm gonna tap it any minute now i'm gonna tap it
guys but you uh what happened i'll tap
wonder what happened i don't know what's good
oh what did i get i got ichika oh leonid i like neonid i
actually selected leonid uh for this i like i don't know i'm
always a sucker for girl bands i think it's really cute all
right i got sake i got kaito he was not my i'm sorry he's
not my favorite vocaloid I do not much care about Kaito.
I think the twins are my favorite.
Oh, it's like we're supposed to be like this.
Oh.
Respect for my teammates, Toya.
It says, What can I do for Shizuku?
Oh.
I got Haruka.
I got Toya again.
I got Ann.
He's letting it casually say.
For the anticipation.
Oh?
Oh my god, Miku!
I got Miku!
Right off the...
I got the main character, guys.
I got the main character right off the bat.
That's right I got four star My Miku's better than your Miku
A streamer's luck It's that Miku Hatsune Four star Nightcord
Miku Just for me Are you sure?
Are you sure?
Look at that I told you I was gonna pull it I told you I
told you Wait, okay, so I have The dinner you take that
back.
I bet you my Miku is better than your Miku.
Look at that Right off the pool of nothing Which one do I
even pull?
All right, increased drop rates for your dream pick.
Oh, this is a double, right?
All right, so this one has the double drop rate so drop rate
increase for new exclusive characters Who are my dream?
All right, guys, let's meta pick who are the best ones i
want where the oh no i i'll pull you choose the yeah i know
but as they said it's my dream pick what's the meta guys
what more stars equals more better yeah but like imagine if
someone dream picked like oh wait they're all four stars
okay recommended is that my recommended the meta is good
that is the all meeku oh you're right all meekus can
actually have all meekus okay but sometimes there's meekus
with different hair colors meta is meta is eight meekus is
this meeku are you meeku oh i can only have one card of each
character no okay i gotta get the twins then okay I have to
get the twins.
The twins are my favorite.
Um.
Are my favorite Vocaloid characters.
But there are Mikus for each band.
Yeah, so like I can't have all Mikus guys.
I already have the Miku.
Atsune Miku on my band.
Uh.
Which was the best Vocaloid?
I mean, sorry.
Which was the best twins?
Oh, she look cute.
She's like, she's winking at me.
She's winking at me, guys.
That look is for me.
Yeah, she was looking at me, guys.
Not you.
Sure.
I like how it's so fair us.
I was like, sure, dokey.
Dokey.
If I click with art?
Wait, oh, wait, what happened to?
No!
I wanted that.
I want that run.
Where is she?
I wanted her!
Yeah.
Where did she go?
She was winking at me like five seconds ago.
Guys, she was winking at me.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, I like that.
Wait, actually.
Oh, wait.
That's cute.
Wait.
That is so cute.
That is actually so cute.
Okay.
Where's Vocaloid?
uh virtual singer okay i need to get one one of len ren and
len okay which one do i want though no no because he's not
confessing to me so now
so no how who is this random girl next to him who is who is
she Let's get that, get her out of here.
Yo, yo.
Alright.
Let's see.
That's cute.
That's a cute Lin.
I don't know.
They're all so cute.
Oh my god, that's Lin and Niku.
I can get both of them at the same time.
Oh.
It's so hard to pick.
I know.
Wait, sorry.
I just like add another, adds another Rin.
Get away from him Alright Let's see Orchestra Len There's
Dancing Len I'll get I'll get Idol Len Alright then we'll
grab one Leonine Why is she here?
I'm sorry I know everybody has a favorite vocal lawyer Why
is she...
Why is she...
He's down.
That was just a little bit kidding.
I do have my favorites.
You gotta...
Let's see what this means right now.
I'm just... I'm browsing!
I'm saying I'm not gonna waste my pulls.
I'm not gonna...
She barely has a whole piece.
favorite no Kaito's my uh Kaito's my least favorite vocaloid
but I um I think it's like the twins then Miku and then
there's like a power gap there's no there's no like four for
there's no like four for fifth or sixth there's like a
there's like a power gap between the next vocaloid
I do, but Kaito is like, yeah, yeah, like Power Scale.
But Kaito's at the, she's not the bottom, bottom, because
there's, she's not the bottom, bottom, though, I will say.
Miku over everyone else.
No, no.
Run and Len over, run, run and Miku over everyone.
It's like, I, run Glen equally, because they're the twins,
so I see them both equally.
one over the other and there's like maybe a small little
like gap between them and Miku and there's a giant power gap
between the rest.
Where is Luca though?
Where is he?
Um just he's somewhere.
We don't have one actually.
Okay I have her.
Oh she's cute.
Actually wait.
I'll get that.
all right i can yes confirm and pull oh wait wait i have
don't worry
i have it all look at all this free stuff guys oh my god i'm
so scrolling oh my god oh my god i can pull for days.
Oh, there they are.
Look at that.
See, guys, I saved 4.5 years of polls for this special day.
Imagine if this account was, like, 4.5 years old, and then
I've, like, never done a single poll until today.
I just celebrate 4.5 years anniversary.
Happy birthday, colorful stage.
passively hoarding income happy birthday there we go i like
it download all right here we go wait we're it's here there
we go but i did pick okay did i not wait where is it oh it's
here okay this is the double the rate and uh pull all right
we got this yeah i'm building interest on building interest
on it how do you guys know when i have four stars like last
time to have to start how did you guys know
i wonder if i could make this wider i feel like it is it all
right oh it's purple when one of the circles is purple okay
sake I don't know if I can make this.
I feel like it's...
I don't know.
It is...
It's not compressed on the screen, right?
I can't tell.
I'll stop until I've written it in.
Alright.
It's rainbow?
Okay.
You want 4-3 or...
You want it to be wider.
Oh, there she is!
There's my cutie.
There's Hanami.
Okay.
I don't even know.
I don't know if my iPad is 4-3.
I cannot tell.
I feel like it's wider.
I don't know if I could fix it.
Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
I'm like, I'm trying to figure out if I could fix it.
Oh, Michael.
Oh, never mind.
She's lower.
I'm sorry.
Michael's lower than Luke.
I will say she's lower than Luke.
I forgot.
I was doing it.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot she was around.
I have no way.
Lucas higher though.
Lucas higher than Michael.
Damn girl.
What is the power scaling of your Miku?
I'll pull again until I get rainbow.
It's not even a rainbow.
There's bottom and then there's who.
like true true i literally forgot about her i was like wait
she's in this game
i'm making enemies but i'm also making fans because i i gave
my team my tier list need the toky vocaloid tier list i know
who she is because of her Like the...
You know the one.
I'm Emu.
I love Wonder...
Wonderland's songs.
I think Wonderland's songs are really cute.
I mean, it is like, you know, their whole thing is about,
like, being happy and everything.
Wonderoy!
I love their songs.
All three kind of a hat would be your sword enemy.
Alright.
I got psyche soggy again
See you at the thank you show I legitimately don't even know
if I could make it a little wider Because I can't tell if
it's supposed to be compressed like this I literally can't
tell I just hope that I hope that it looks okay on stream
there i get let's see i got oh kane noises where are my
spell i hit me my ren and len like i need i need ren and len
pull again it's okay i have 4.5 years of pull this here oh
my god still not rainbow i used it all up on the goth on the
goth me too
um this is my third pull oh there she is yeah you know i got
ren that's true it was worth it i got my ren though yeah i
know it's a square i don't know how to i don't know i don't
know how to change the result i can google it uh my game
capture is a square How to fix.
Oh, Len!
Hey!
Oh my god, he's so emo.
He has so much, like, emo vibes right there.
Oh, Mizuki.
Oh, she's so cute.
She's so cute.
Yeah, emo boy, Toya.
I don't know, you got my Rin and Len, but then they're not
four-star Rin and Len, though, so is it really worth?
Is it...
Are they even good enough to be on my team?
What's that word when he's like, that small?
Is it smolder?
When they're, like, super emo, and like, oh, look at that.
Look at him.
Three stars are decent.
I don't settle for decent.
My team is not...
I don't play around here.
We are not a decent family.
We go for it.
We go home.
Exactly.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out.
Uh, my game capture is square.
How to fix.
How to unsquare it.
Uh.
iPad.
Maybe if I add...
iPad at the end we're doing it live okay does not match to
fix this change your to match your or stretch the source uh
to fit the screen
uh ensure the game running is outputting a regular capture
card can properly what does that even mean.
What?
Alright, never mind.
It's fine.
We pull again.
Great start.
Alright.
Wait, is that rainbow?
Or is that green?
I'm not colorblind, by the way.
Oh, it's rainbow, right?
I was like Can't tell Is this a green or is that rainbow?
Oh, it's rainbow.
Oh my god, I see it.
I see it.
I see that one circle.
Oh, this better be Rin or Len.
I swear to God.
If I get If I swear to God, Luca, if you show up I swear to
God If it's Kaito or Luca Or if it, oh my God.
Oh, it's Wonderland Miku.
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
But she's not as cute.
as good as Goff Miku.
Watch her get...
Imagine it's a four-star Kaito.
Don't do this to me.
I don't deserve that.
Alright, there's M.
Oh, I have the good for the Goff version of her.
Alright, Kanane.
I don't hate him.
It's just... I stomp!
I take that back.
I...
Manifest...
You manifest...
No, I...
Now I have a reason to hate him.
Now...
Four star guy.
That's a fucking...
He's not even there!
At least all the other vocal loins are there like he's he
doesn't even bother showing up in person like yeah now it's
personal the other vocaloid that showed yeah he's he's
literally just a hologram don't keep but you can upgrade him
too like here's the game thought you deserve the kite deal
he will when you upgrade him probably don't he just upgrade
him like a star like he doesn't now for the things to see
other vocalists show up physically this guy's fucking is
calling in from zoom he's punished by the game i why are you
in here why are you on my team i'm sorry to all the kites of
love but
Sorry, though, really They work Bro, his bro is working From
home
Alright, please Four stars Four star twins, I do have I have
to pull for other stuff Wait, let me double check if there's
anything else Okay, no I could just pull for this, okay I'm
sorry, I just I have to double check because I got what I
wanted on the the premium gift gotcha wait is there anything
else I need to get for the premium gift gotcha before I
accidentally spend it all on this one I just have to be sure
is there anything else I need to get on the premium the the
4.5 year anniversary or did I got all the good I literally
just got Gov Miku, so I don't know if there's anything
better than that.
I got all the anniversary stuff, too, I'm pretty sure.
No, I have more.
I have more gems.
I was like, there's no...
Guys, I can't pull another guy.
Then I pull a fucking guy, though.
I...
Oh, my God.
Whoa.
I swear to God, if I...
in our i swear to god um there he is brooding as always he's
brooding right now
oh oh i got another miku
oh look at that they're practicing so hard right now
get him off my screen get him off here wait i want to double
check if i am if there's anything else Uh, one limited time
from your pick list, guaranteed.
Do I have everything?
Yeah, I can do it.
My pick list, okay.
What if I have, if I put all Rinn and Lenn, then...
Alright.
Oh, this one's cute.
Oh, this art is cute.
Okay, and then...
Oh, I do only?
Really?
Um, I guess I'll put The other Meekus.
Oh my god, I have to add One of them
Okay, you know what?
Wait, let's see
She's the highest out of all of them So I'll pick her No, I
do I do have enough Do I?
Yeah.
I don't.
Never mind.
Okay, let's go back.
Sorry.
I don't know how to do math.
I don't know if that's sort of obvious.
Sorry.
I sort of forgot how to do the math.
I can't, but...
Wait, did I do this already?
I...
Wait, I need to...
Wait, I need to make sure.
I'm trying to make sure I didn't mess it up.
Wait, did I spend the paint gems on this one?
There's no way.
I have spent it up.
Guys, which one did I pull last set?
The first pull?
Was the first pull this one?
Oh, wait, I can pull this.
Guys, free gotcha.
Guys, this one's free Oh, I'm the adversary outfit banner
Okay, that's good Okay, I was a little scared I messed up I
have free pulls here The first hour is just pulls As it
should be I have a lot to catch up on I was, I That was my
freak That was Oh Okay
Okay, kaito I can't escape He's always there Get to another
tent He just he's always there Kaito come home All right
rent oh a virtual salarone though that's cute and then we
have suzuku and then mafuyu oh did she did she see the
message oh she wanted to see oh she wanted to confess in
person oh that's cute lazy bones they even give the tier one
sub to kyle they thank you all right i do have another i
have another free pull is there anything else just so i
don't waste it is there anything else i can use it for just
to be sure i don't want to get i was like no i'm too cute
you quite have used it on that one
only okay that's good so you guys look at this free stuff
all right i'll do another one and another one
all right it's three stars though get that out of here no
you're gonna miss the kaito exclusive oh what a shame oh
what a shame
I can't believe it.
I'm so stupid.
How could I miss the Kaito exclusive banner?
Oh, I'm so foolish.
Oh, no.
Guess I gotta wait another 4 for 5 years to do it.
To do it the full.
It's a huge update, guys.
By the way, I will be doing some multiplayer.
I gotta figure out how to do it.
With some of the dragons, so make sure to click the link
pinned in the chat or use the command exclamation point Miku
to join and download the game.
It is free, guys.
Remember, this is a free game.
It is a free...
I know it is, surprisingly, it is a rhythm game.
I know we're not there yet, but guys, I swear to God, guys,
there is gameplay.
I'm just trying to catch up right now.
I need my twins
All right, that used up on my free stuff.
Okay, and then we're back here now
This is the best banner right?
Yeah, I need to power up my units before heading into battle
exactly exactly
Yeah So this is the best banner.
Okay, I just wanted to be certain.
Why are you still here?
I'm sorry I just at this point.
I'll collect them all At this point I'll have all the kaitos
There's like there's like 40 band players.
There's like 40 musicians.
They can't all be kaito Number one kaito There's like 40
different characters.
Why is Kaito still here?
Wait.
Or can they?
Collect all the Kaito's account.
One, Ruin, and Lid.
It's like manifest destiny.
I swear every pull of Kaito has to show up.
Every single pull.
Who invited him?
Who?
He could show up at any other party Who invited him to my
party Alright I swear you guys You were so cool Kaito I saw
K and I was just like Who is he?
He just walks in We invited him He's like I heard you're my
biggest fan From the dragons The coalition of Kaito's all
right we go again we still have so many
where's my double where's my double race for ren and len
they gave me everybody for ren and len i swear to god i
swear to god if he shows up again i swear he has gone all
right it's okay minori
fashion for Miku.
I swear.
I swear to God.
I do have...
And he takes my three-poet slot.
The self-fulfilling prophecy.
He's like...
I heard you're my biggest fan.
Okay, there.
That's good.
Progress.
No Kaito?
Oh my...
There we go.
We broke the... We broke the curse.
Oh!
This is the Lia- Lia-Nin.
Uh...
Miku too, right?
She's so cute.
There we go.
Let's go, baby.
I still have more free gems.
Just spend it all.
That's a cute Miku, though.
Kaito, come home.
It's crazy.
I don't think we got a single Michael.
I don't think we got a single one yet.
I literally don't even think she's in our team.
many balls.
Oh, Mako, right?
Is that how you pronounce your name?
Guys, I'm sorry.
I don't even know.
I'm so sorry.
I don't even know how to pronounce your name.
I told you, there's a tier list, but she's not in my tier
list.
I don't,
it's not hate.
It's more like difference because I forgot she was in this
game.
I legit, I forgot, not even forgot she was, I forgot she
existed.
I legit, look, I told you my tier, my Vocaloid Power Scale
leveling is Rin Len equally, and then a little bit of a gap,
and then Miku, and then there's a giant gap between the
next, the next Vocaloid for me.
Oh, there she is!
My first one, okay, that's a cute one though.
That's a cute one, though.
It's not the original style.
Alright, I got...
Eno.
Alright, pull again.
My first Mako.
Or Mako?
Is that how you pronounce your name?
Oh!
Another rainbow!
Kaichō!
Mako?
Okay, Mako.
Alright, let's see who my rainbow is.
Oh, I have a gold and a rainbow.
The four...
It's okay.
I got him as a two-star.
He can't be a four-star now.
Oh, my god.
Wait, is this my four-star?
Yeah!
Okay, I have to get a four-star red now.
I have to.
Like, you can't have Len without Rin.
Oh my god.
And I get original style Len too.
Okay.
Am I fool you?
Alright.
You can't have Len without Rin.
They're a pair.
I...
Okay.
It's okay.
I saw a brooding man.
And I was like, is that...
Do you bear?
Can I tell that it doesn't brood though?
He's always so happy.
Okay.
It was like vaguely blue and I was like, I swear to you,
guy.
Oh, another rainbow!
Two in a row!
Is this my pity pose?
Is this...
Oh my god.
A two for a double rainbow.
Back to back, baby.
Alright.
Akito.
And then I Oh my god, please be a three Please be a three I
do not need four Please Oh, thank God, okay Okay, I was
gonna say I do not need four I don't need two four stars
Kaito's I can't even play both of them Oh my Okay, that was
a three That was, thank God That was a 30 star I was like
What am I gonna do with two four star Kaito's That was a
real fear What am I gonna do?
I can't even play both of them.
It doesn't matter.
It's still giving me a...
No, there's no way.
They can't do this to me.
They can't.
I just need a friend.
I mean, at least she is cute.
I got Honami.
At least she's cute.
At least...
At least, at least it's not Kaito.
Oh, is she the...
Oh!
Okay, I got Ichika.
Alright.
I can do two more pulls.
I still know Ren.
I still have no four star Ren.
Which I am a little salty above.
No more rainbow.
Not no triple.
No, oh baby a triple.
for me.
I'm so blue hair close enough.
Wait, wait.
That's a rainbow!
Wait, triple!
Oh, baby!
A triple!
Wait a minute.
I got, it baited me.
Oh my God.
It changed.
Okay, it's okay.
I got Kaito as a two star, so there's no way I'll give me a
four star Kaito.
I blew my whole butt.
There's no way.
They gave me a two star.
Oh my god, it's all Vocaloid.
Okay.
Oh my god, wait.
This is like a godpole.
It's a Godpack.
It's a Vocaloid Godpack.
It's literally all Vocaloid.
It's all Vocaloid.
Oh.
It put invited Nen.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I guess like the last remaining ones are...
Or... I like how it's like...
Oh, wait.
The first two are not...
It was like Vocaloid, Vocaloid, Vocaloid, Vocaloid,
Vocaloid.
And then the last two and the first two...
Are the...
The other singers.
I mean...
I guess...
Three-wheeler with a three-wheeler.
She has a three-wheeler.
Yes.
Our last pull.
Can I get a quadruple rainbow?
Oh.
Look at that.
I can.
Let it ride.
Dude, no way.
All right.
This is it.
This is the final countdown.
This is where it all lies.
And I just, I need, all I need is a four star Rhin.
That's all I need.
I have everyone else.
I have all the four stars of all the other vocalists, except
for Luca, I guess.
I think, I think the only, the highest is three star.
I just need Rhin.
I legitimately just need Rhin.
This all lies.
here on my last pool I think I have everyone but Luca and
Rin for four stars this is a this is a Rin summoning ritual
oh my god two yellows too no it's just one it's just one
rainbow okay Minori all right Saki Minori.
And then...
I haven't seen a Ren in so long.
She's my force!
Okay.
Well, I have Honami, I guess.
I think I already have a four-star Honami, too.
It's fine.
She's tech.
I mean, it's almost blonde.
It's almost up.
I mean, she's sort of blind if you think about it.
Does Rin even exist in this game?
Is there a way for me to get a...
Why have any...
What's there?
Is there...
Is there a way for me?
Is there a way for me to get...
To get...
Oh, oh?
Oh, wait.
I could get Ren here.
Oh.
Okay.
All right, we'll open this first.
Okay, guys, I will...
Guys, I need a Ren.
Guys, you don't understand.
Okay, I already have her.
Guys.
My team cannot be complete without a Ren.
Guys, I'm trying to optimize my team.
Do you want my team to be unoptimized, guys?
The multiplayer is a team game.
We can't win if Rin's not on the team.
You guys don't care about winning.
How can we be optimized without Rin on the team?
Oh my god, I got Ari.
Sounds like a you problem.
Oh, it's another yellow.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Maybe, guys.
Just for you.
Maybe.
Do I have anything?
maybe maybe maybe maybe no maybe no how do I get more free
pulls guys wait look at the clipboard oh it's just 100 all
right it's just What am I going to do with 900?
All right.
Okay.
I got to build my team.
How do I build my team?
Training.
Character rank.
All right.
Level up characters for special rewards.
Okay.
Why even have enough for...
Oh, claim all.
Oh.
Yay!
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god.
He gives me crystals.
Oh my god, wait.
This changes everything.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I get more pulls.
Okay, wait.
Okay, I got hurt.
Look at that.
I stockpiled 4.5 years.
it free pulls incoming i like how they're very what's the
word um they're very nice with like uh with all the free
stuff which i like too there's a what's the generous they're
very generous with it the fact that i can get free pulls
from just like i don't even know how they're upgrading oh
it's is it from my other pulls because I have a lot of them
oh is it because it's like the duplicates right that's what
level leveling them I'm swear let's see how I'm gonna see
how I have 12 Miku's all right Kaito what's your rank
nine okay nine okay not the fact that he's my second highest
ranked Vocaloid though That Kaito-fa- Wait, how do I put
that on?
He's actually my second highest Vocaloid.
That's crazy.
I mean, Miko makes sense.
It makes sense for...
How do I equip my title?
What?
Is it... profile?
I have a default.
Or is it Taito?
Okay.
I've just accepted it, guys.
I've just, I've accepted my fate.
He's there for a reason.
Okay, I have enough for more pulls.
Okay.
Nice.
Don't be rude Okay, okay, I'll do one more pull and I'll do
a song, guys I'll, I just, guys, I need to get, guys don't
understand, I need to optimize my team Okay, okay, I'll do
one more pull I'll do one more pull and then And then
Is this one, yeah Oh, wait, wait, what, why?
Why was I okay one time only I was gonna say I could pay.
Oh, this is for paid gems Okay Two more you're right two
more pulls.
Oh my god another rainbow.
This is it Are you?
Are you sure we don't understand guys right after this
Right after this guys
Okay Right after Oh my god, oh my god Yeah,
I got it!
She's winking at me, guys, by the way.
You guys didn't know?
You guys didn't know.
She was winking at me.
I told you.
Let's...
Yo, I told you.
I told you she's coming home.
I told you.
I never stopped rolling.
There we go.
We did it.
See?
Just one more pull.
That's all we needed, guys.
Okay, these guys don't matter anymore.
I got who I wanted.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
All right, I think my team is optimized now.
All right.
And then build my team.
Do this.
Get these people out of here.
If you're not five stars, leave.
What's this?
Recommended?
Auto.
Who would they recommend?
He's not even there!
Oh!
Okay, of course they win.
And as the leader, too.
As the number one kind of my leader.
They put a three star over it.
Over the four star red.
Supreme leader kind of.
I mean, I don't title.
Time to see him.
Let me change it.
I'm typing with one finger, by the way.
Alright, well, we gotta fix this team, obviously.
We got...
We gotta...
Alright, get him out of here.
Alright, just show me all the four stars.
Like, why would they put a four-star movie?
Okay.
Alright, Rin has to be the leader.
Like, I'm sorry.
Okay, Rin, and then...
Wait, no, Miku has to be the...
What?
How did...
How did Kaito get over Miku?
Wait!
I just realized.
Why did...
Why was...
Why was Miku co-leader?
exactly the game knows all right you you i do need a four
star go over here wait i can have anyone but him i don't
have other people other girls and then we'll put her okay
we're gonna put and now then hey who is it five one anyone
better okay she's obviously better all right there you go
and this girl there's honami i don't know their names yet so
i mean i could have a full vocaloid team like it would make
more sense okay but then their their thing isn't all right i
think that's fine what's the support group oh i don't have
any support group stuff all right that's fine okay now we
can play a song guys
unless guys give me a sec we could play a song right unless
which one is it your free it shows okay so there's the story
event oh there you go adjust bonus energy all right now we
can do rhythm all right we gotta do the new song where is it
all right uh
Thank you.
Why are you here?
Why did they pick him to congratulate me?
There's 80 characters.
I heard you were a kind of fan.
It feels...
Why is he...
I have...
He's not even the leader.
Shouldn't the leader be like...
good job?
He can't escape him.
I don't understand.
Shouldn't the leader be the one to say good job, Toki?
It's random.
It's only he is the true leader.
He is the leader.
Alright.
Oh
Okay It's okay
my I Love my virtual singers.
Don't worry.
I have one.
I do, but I don't think I need it
It's all right
Okay I'm trying to make sure.
Oh, I can put the Porter Robinson outfit.
Oh, on in my Sakai.
Oh, I heard this one.
It's like a little tiny village, right?
Hello.
Yeah, a little house.
You're finally here.
I sure am.
At least Miku's here for me.
New Sakai is about to be born.
Can't guess who is me, right?
Who could it be?
The feeling of the Sakai belongs to you.
I thought you might be surprised by a feeling that one day,
your own Sakai would be born.
Thank you, Miku.
My favorite virtual...
Well, no, you're not my favorite, but you're almost there.
You feel...
I will say...
She does have the best figures.
I will say.
My third favorite.
You cry with him and then you...
You smile for them.
And I'm sure your Sekai was born from all these feelings and
emotions combined.
So are you ready?
Come on, let's go visit your new Sekai.
Alright.
It's fine.
Aw, she's so cute!
That's cute.
So this is your...
There's nothing here yet.
Maybe because it's just born?
If you're here on out, your feelings will fill this place
with color.
What's that?
There's a house over there.
Maybe it's yours.
That's me.
I'm naked.
How do I...
How do I walk?
I was just born.
Miku, how do I walk?
I haven't seen the walk yet.
Walking is so hard.
Just a little time.
Thank you.
How do I walk?
I'm tapping.
Oh my god.
Why are you so?
Oh, I have to hold.
I was gonna say, why are you so slow?
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
There we go.
I have to tap on the left side.
I can sit down.
Hello.
Oh, so this way looks like inside.
You think it feels a little empty?
I'm broke, Miku Hatsune.
I spent it all on Kaito.
But since this is your Sakai, it should respond to your
feelings.
All right.
Oh, I got a dresser and I got a bed blueprint.
Are those blueprints?
I see.
Alright.
To make the items on these blueprints look like you'll need
to find the materials in the sick guy.
It seems these materials are born from your feelings.
Maybe your sick guy wants to discover all sorts of feelings.
Yes, exactly.
First things first, get out here and look for those
materials.
All right.
I gotta look for materials now.
Where are they?
Okay.
My open door.
Oh, there's a little field.
Alright.
Goodbye, Miku.
Okay.
Oh, I can chop.
Top and hold down.
Uh, to recover.
Different object yields different materials.
Okay, I gotta chop some trees.
That's enough trees.
Okay, 10.
We're almost there.
That's cute, though.
This is a cute little bonus stuff.
After you're done...
After you're done playing your rhythm stuff, you can relax
out here.
You can relax out here with all your friends.
And her name is Miku.
I have all the materials.
Honey, fluffy, cotton.
Alright.
it's time to pick up some cotton
all right
i have enough yeah i did it i did one song i did one song
guys guys you know why i haven't done the multiplayer yet
because i'm giving all of you guys time to optimize your
team when i play multiplayer because i'll be playing with
you guys i'll be playing with my dragoons in in the Hatsune
Miku colorful stage which you can download right now by
clicking on the link pinned in my chat where do exclamation
point Miku guys I'm giving you guys time to do gotcha yeah
I'm waiting for you guys to optimize your team I'm so
considerate the workbench appeared while you were gone use
this to make the items on the blueprints with Peter as he
gathered.
I can't wait to see how it turns out.
Okay.
I know I'm so nice.
Let's craft some furniture.
All right.
Let me craft this.
Obviously, I need a bed.
Okay, furniture built.
And then we're going to need a dresser.
All right.
Got everything.
I know.
Try placing them in your room.
Okay.
Is it, though, how many Kairos do you have in your team?
How many virtual singers do you have, huh?
Is it truly optimized?
I was going to put it in front of my door and I'll never
leave.
Can I actually put him?
Oh, I can't.
They won't let me put it in front of my door.
I just...
I was just gonna put it there.
It's not fair.
I can't be trapped in my own home.
Yay, look.
Miku, conflict you made it in my room.
You take a little break now that you sub your bed.
I'll wait for you outside so take all the time you need.
Yay!
Oh my god.
More rolls.
You sleep time.
Oh.
Not sleep time?
Just disassociating for a little bit.
You know?
Apparently you can visit other people's worlds too.
How do I...
Oh, Miku wants to talk to me.
What do you want to talk about, Miku, the virtual singer?
Look at this.
No, I didn't put it here.
I just noticed him, yes.
I'm surprised as you are.
I can feel powerful emotions coming from the other side of
it.
And I think they belong to people y'all know too well.
Perhaps your feelings and yours are trying to connect.
You might be able to encounter some wonderful, wonderful
what?
Oh, someone's coming.
I guess this is where I take my leave.
But remember, I'll always be watching over your set guy.
She's always watching you, guys.
Always watching.
Goodbye, Miku.
Who is it?
Who's coming over?
Oh!
Wonderful!
Is that?
Is this?
Is this guaranteed?
Can I get any other bed?
What is this?
What is it?
ever jenny is this like scripted go out or is it randomized
please tell me this was scripted they would always come
is this is this event scripted i need to know or is it like
it's randomized that any like any of the team of teams can
join.
Does any...
Okay, they're always first.
Okay.
It's...
They're always first.
Okay.
Thank God.
I swear.
You were your number one fan.
I didn't even choose Wonder Story.
I chose Leo Need.
I didn't even choose them!
I chose the girl band!
He chose for me.
Hello.
Meaning to govern.
Yeah, soaring Pegasus.
I'm Sukasa Tenma.
You're looking at trope leader, Wonderland Showtime.
It's Showtime.
And a future Shazara, it's nice to meet you.
When can I change clothes?
Hello, Miku.
I'll talk to you.
Oh, I see.
It was only just created.
God, it's the yard's empty for now, but you're planning a
bunch of stuff to make it more fun?
I can't wait to see how it turns out.
I wonder if I can...
I don't want to change clothes.
I don't want to be...
Oh, it should be my dresser, right?
That's what dressing is for.
I guess not.
I can only sleep.
I just want to put on my new clothes.
I'll put on my Porter Robinson collab outfit on my Sakai.
Okay.
Inventory.
Okay, there we go.
This is it.
The Smiles Avatar.
There it is.
There she is.
I can be yellow, though.
Okay.
I can be red.
I can be blue.
I can be...
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, I have, like...
Oh, let me go.
Wait, I have like...
Does that mean if I don't have...
Oh, wait, no.
Okay.
I was gonna say...
There we go.
Now I can.
Alright.
I leave now.
Apparently I can visit other people's worlds.
Why this door?
Where's my grow bed?
Where is that?
I picked the grow bed first.
Oh, if I'm done with tutorial, then I can visit other
people's worlds.
I'm not done with the tutorial.
How do I visit other people's worlds?
I want to visit people's worlds.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
No.
Oh.
my god that was part of the tutorial i have to watch them
come over again i know
okay all right i have to talk okay i'll talk to everybody
it's nice to meet you i'm done
I will say they have they have my favorite song I always
love wonderful opportunity they're my favorite they're my
favorite group I love all their songs
There's a director.
Yeah, don't I look cute?
Are you?
I see!
Oh, that's your avatar.
I see.
So this place is still...
Excuse me.
place um excuse me would you be incomplete hello
this is complete he's so rude you look okay
it's minimalistic i still have introduced myself oh wait
wait all right let's talk to you we'll save the best for
last.
Aww.
Crayed by Sukasa's feelings.
Oh, see?
Look, she says I look cute.
No, I already talked to him earlier.
Look, see?
She wasn't like, Oh, She's like, Oh, you're so cute!
And I'm like, I know!
Oh, no, I can't.
She's lying to you.
All right, we saved the best for last, guys.
Hello, I'm Kaito.
I put on shows with Miku and Sukasa Sakai.
I have to say, your Sakai is overflowing, not just feelings,
but fond memories and powerful emotions as well.
It seems it's a brand new Sakai, which means it can become
whatever you want it to be.
At least that's what I feel.
Now I'm here.
Now we can chill.
You want my yard?
Wait.
Who said that?
Who's they?
I know I didn't say it.
I had to clean the stuff at the yard.
I have to make it.
Are you guys gonna help me make it?
Oh, they are.
Okay.
I swear to God, they're just standing around.
Are they actually going to help me?
They were the ones that suggested having a yard, I guess.
Make a yard where everyone can play.
Okay.
I guess who has to clean these benches?
All right, guys.
You guys want to, you know, chop some wood for me?
I need a park tires what are you gonna do with park tires
are we children like the bench that makes sense what are you
gonna do with the tires like are we gonna stand on top of it
like how how do you play on that okay they are important I
understand the bench to sit down What do I need?
What is that?
Okay, resin.
Hey, guys, want to...
Mika, do you want help?
I guess I would put...
I get how hard I choose when...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I guess I have to...
Oh.
Time to gather.
I had...
Do I just have, like, five supervisors?
Like...
How do I get sticky resin?
I don't know how to play with...
up.
I was gonna say, what am I gonna do with park tires?
I know they exist.
Like, I've seen it in the park, in the playground, but I
don't know, like, what's like the purpose of a park tire?
Like, like, as a, I guess it's like a border?
Where do you get rest?
Instructions have been so unclear.
There's like seven supervisors, and I'm the worker here like
guys you guys gotta tell me where to get these mats
like nail where am i gonna get okay fledging field okay okay
wait i don't even
okay i i guess i'll there's nails Who's leaving nails?
Who's leaving nails in the woods?
Who's leaving nails in the goddamn woods?
Oh, they gave me materials already.
I'm sorry.
I was...
I thought to collect.
Okay, that's...
I'm glad they actually helped.
I didn't even notice that.
Okay, we're going to put my yellow.
Wait, actually, one yellow.
I didn't even realize I had it.
I was so zoned in just being like, where am I going to get
sticky resin when I can't even access?
I was actually, I was going to be like, whoa!
And then blue for Kaito.
All right, at least, you know, they actually were helping.
gonna just I'll grab all right nice okay now I can place it
put that oh I have to actually place it exactly there there
you go and then the tire in front of the chair it's it's so
he can look at how beautiful the tires are what a view Wait,
what a beautiful view.
Oh, that is.
Oh, I got all the plushies of everybody.
All right, please leave.
Just one of you, though.
You can all say, I just want one of you to leave.
I wonder who that one is.
All right.
Yeah, they had so fun watching me build stuff.
Yo, Kaito!
Yo, that's me!
Bye!
Bye, guys.
I'll see you later.
Alright.
Oh, now I can change it.
Okay.
Empty.
Sekai gate.
Oh, is this where I can visit other people's gates?
Now?
This is empty.
Oh, do they all...
Oh, they all come in here.
It's...
It's emo, Miku.
Why is Wonderhoi get... Wonderhoi get like two virtual
singers?
I forgot they're called empty.
I was like, oh, it's an empty one.
That's me!
Yeah, I'm the owner.
Yeah,
well, welcome.
Welcome to my crib.
Yeah, why can't they be first?
Oh, are they like, do I have to get all the gates before I
lock it?
She's like the least email.
She actually, like, has joy in her life.
Editing our music videos.
Oh, that's cute.
Yeah, this is me.
No, it's actually completed.
Yeah, she still has hope in her eyes.
Yeah, I love it.
But it is done.
But...
What do you mean?
It's done already.
Oh,
oh, she's the artist!
Yeah, I'm a little baby.
I was just born.
Yeah.
All right, I'll talk to Miku last.
Oh, she's the depressed one.
I'm doing like a spark notes of all the members right now.
Yeah.
to talk to her.
Yeah, she feels like she's dead inside.
Wait, they all have jobs.
Oh, no, this one too.
Why are they all...
Uh, Colin.
I like how, like, the group is sort of separated between the
happy ones and then the the sad one.
It's the first two I talked to.
They were so happy.
And then the sad ones are in the corner.
All right, hey, Miku.
Because even this Miku is sad.
I'm surprised I can enter a Sakai there in my fooyus.
You want to be friends?
Sure, I like that too.
Yay!
I'm friends with Miku now.
Is that easy?
Okay, I have to go back to my bed.
The extroverts and the introverts.
Yeah.
I'm best friends with Hatsune Miku.
Wait.
She's in my room.
I'm tight like that.
Yeah, I'm tight with her like that.
Yeah, I called Miku by her first name.
Wait, yeah, that's it.
Hasuna is the last name.
Yeah.
The more work I'll be to decorate.
All right.
What am I supposed to do here?
They told me to...
What?
Why is she here?
Okay.
Hello.
I was about to leave.
Oh,
she got
What do you mean?
Sorry, I'm a minimalistic decorator.
It's true though.
It's true.
My, I, my room is like a single, it's like a bachelor pad.
You know what's, what's in my bedroom?
It's one bed.
I don't even have a dresser.
I do.
I have a dresser and then my dresser has like socks in it.
It's just socks.
There's like nothing else.
There's nothing on the walls.
There's nothing else.
It's one bed and then one dresser.
And a dresser has socks in it.
I have a closet.
There's clothes in there.
Oh, and then also the doggy stairs.
So my dog doesn't fucking break his back again.
yeah
let's say like what else do I have oh I have a giant box in
the corner filled with clothes I haven't unpacked yet no the
underwear is in the closet of course I have a giant
cardboard box that's just filled with clothes that I haven't
unpacked that's just there in the corner the box corner
bedroom.
All right.
They want decorations.
I don't even have decorations in my actual room.
I'm a Zuki.
It's not even in my own real room.
All right.
She wants a makeover.
Refine.
All right.
Obtain a plant.
Live up your Wallace with...
Oh, okay, that's cute.
Um...
Oh, I had to make it.
I thought she gave me it.
Do you not...
Oh, Wallace.
There it is.
Oh my...
Okay, I guess I have to...
I have to make it.
A clock and plant.
Well, she must have given me the mats.
Okay, she did.
At least she gave me the materials, like the others.
Um...
I'll do blue for Kaito.
Alright, and then...
Ooh!
Okay, okay, that is a...
I'm a sucker for pastel.
I love pastel colors.
I think I like the peach one the most.
I'm gonna grab...
Yeah, I'm gonna grab the peach.
The OG color.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, put the clock right here so I can tell the time and
then we'll put the plant.
Can I put under the table, imagine?
We'll put the plant like right next to my bed.
So it's like, it's like my pet, you know?
But yeah, but then put in the corner.
Actually I'll put in the corner.
Yeah, put in this corner.
There we go.
nine oh save there you go the quarter of shame that to leave
now I like how I put the plant far away from the window I
think it's like a cactus too right it's never getting any
sun oh thank you see they said my room was really nice I'm
bad with plants i i don't own any plants whatsoever because
every time when i was younger every time i own a plant it
does i was so bad i either over watered it or like i just
don't water it enough
Yeah, they said good job.
Guys, I did a good job.
Thank you.
Thank you, Amiku.
I think so, too.
All right.
Yeah, I did it.
I guess I still have the other bands.
When will Leonid come to my sec guy?
I want Leonid.
Yes.
It's the last one!
I can't believe it.
Okay, maybe I should do a collab song right now.
Maybe I should do multiplayer right now.
I'm sorry.
I just wanted to see here.
I wanted to see other people's sick guy.
There's no way it can be better than my place though.
Mizuki said my house was really pretty.
So, um, the Mizu- So, I think I would win.
Yeah.
See, Ina says my house is peaked.
Yeah, Chutoro is, I guess, because, like, every, um, every
band is visiting.
I hope the audio has been great throw it at it yay okay
who's next anyway I'm gonna go we can okay it's more and
more jump alright let's let's do a little home alright guys
it's time wait I could buy a music too get new signs do I
have enough money oh they have to Taurus they have Toho
Wonderland Oh my god, wait, which they have so many, Tico
signs Oh, this is hard, wait, how much Does it cost?
Oh, I have enough Guys, you think I'm I was like, I have
enough?
I have so much, I'm fine What's this?
Okay, it's just news Oh, which one would be Old Miss?
I'm trying to see, I don't know I'm trying to see if they
have some of my I know like there's already some of my
favorites already in.
So I'm gonna see if there's like other ones that like, I
don't, I like tutorials.
Tutor is good.
Wait, they have rumor?
Oh, this is a different rumor.
I was like, oh, rumor.
But I was thinking about a different, I was thinking about
like an English song that's called rumor.
I was like, do you have rumor?
That change is a classic.
It is.
There's so many songs.
You play all your favorite songs.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
There's Dufu all back.
I'm seeing if they have any classic.
Like, oh there's Magical Cure Love Shot.
I'm trying to see if there's an oldie classic.
Oh, there's Goddess.
I'm trying to see if they have like a classic classic.
You have Shanti?
I recognize that.
Oh my god.
I have this figure.
I don't remember the song.
I don't know if anyone remembers this, but this was
considered.
This song.
This song was considered a...
A grail.
Like the figure for it.
The scaled figure.
This was a grail.
And I have this one.
I have this exact.
figure.
I bought this so long ago.
I remember I saw it at this, like, I remember when they
first released it.
I was like, I had to get it.
I've never listened to the song.
This is what we, I remember I'd never listened to the song
when I got the figure.
Um, but I just loved it.
It's in a box.
It's in a box within a box somewhere.
I bought it when it first came out.
That's how long ago it was when it very first came out I
believe I believe all the classic songs that I would have
already own like it's already like in as like a free song oh
there's phony I'm trying to see there's one that's like
super classic that I can buy vampire goodbye oh it the
classic cover oh remote we have to do remote control oh my
that's one of my favorite i i love wonderful opportunity so
it's like legit one of my my favorite producers
okay okay donut hole wait it's donut hole that's a classic
that was an insta buy for me oh
I don't.
Wait, is this?
No, it's not the song.
Oh my god, Servant of Evil!
That's, I love the, the mad videos.
The mad videos from Servant of Evil and Daughter of Evil.
Every time it's Halloween, a YouTuber would release that
cover I love the I love the mad videos the oh my god they
were all so good what is the one where it was like the first
sin is blah blah blah the killers um ah that one is a
classic virtual singer song ah I'm trying to remember it's
like the first person it was a bad end night where it was
like oh these are all how all these uh these are how all
these characters died or something i don't know if they have
it here is it alice it might be alice i'm just thinking
about all the classics like classic mad videos okay oh my
god i'm sorry we're going to be doing a lot of these of all
the songs i I Rolling girl, Zembo.
I have I have Rin Len and Miku figures of the from this song
I love the character design for this
What's this I don't know any I don't really know any of the
newer songs but like I have the grail figure for this too
the classic one I was so mad when they re-released it I was
actually I was just like cause like um because it was so
hard to get but when because it was so hard to get the
figure for that and I was so mad because like I finally got
it it was considered a grail as well it was considered a
grail and I finally was able to get it and they re-release
it had a re-release like i think a month or two after i got
bought the figure and i was so mad because like obviously it
was so expensive it was so expensive because um they only
had at that time they only released they had only one
release for it i was so mad i was like oh Now you were I was
just like
I hate it when that happens I was like oh my god I finally
have this Grail figure Those who don't know Grail I don't
know if it's still called Grail But like it's like the It's
like everybody's like I want This figure type Shit so
they're like that It's considered a Grail because it's like
One of like the figures that you want in your collection I
don't collect figures anymore I just collect myself now But
Okay, all right, we got it Okay, now I'm ready I'm ready to
play for real Give me a sec, let me look through Yeah, like
a holy grail
I just want to make sure If I bought all the songs I want to
buy
Let's see
I don't buy Oh wait, is this one No, do they have Alice?
I'll buy it.
This one's a classic too.
Do they have Alice in here?
I don't know why I missed it.
Yeah, but I could ask you guys.
Online game addicts.
I've never heard of this song, but it's me.
Alice might be too dark.
It is a really dark song, but I love the videos for it.
they don't I hope they add Alice in the future that's such a
classic though you have irony
where shall we go
see I'm surprised do they is what's the one where Miku is
like in uh in like a sand like a dune is that in here
because that's also a classic song that one i like that one
what is it called is it actually just called sand planet
yeah did it have sand planet in here
no sand planet that one's a classic dude oh love is war i
have this i got the grail figure for this too and then they
also re-released it why supply and demand I have I have a
grill figure for that too and they re-released it every time
every time oh it is Dune it's not sad planet yeah what's the
point of treasure they just make more dredging it is okay i
didn't see it yet oh i have envy baby i'm sorry i'm shopping
right now and this entire stream sponsor stream is just me
shopping but having a good time it gives me serotonin
supply demand wait pop Oh, it's not the song I was thinking
of.
I don't know why I thought the song was.
I don't even know what...
I don't even know what that song is.
Is it?
So many good ones.
Oh, they have Queen as well.
What's this?
I've never heard of this.
I've never heard of this song before.
like wait is that sonic i mean sorry that's not obviously
that's not i was just like sorry that's amy but like i was
like me oh wait they have they did a collab is it
is that pink sonic oh wait there's shadow Oh, it's a, yeah,
Sonic Racing collab.
Oh, wait, I like the song, too.
I have the song in my, on my playlist.
That's one, I like that one.
I feel like I've not seen...
I have not seen Dune here yet.
Or is...
dude.
I'm out by Taurus.
Oh,
this that's one of my favorites too.
I'm sorry.
I'm just going through memory lane.
I know I do not talk about like virtual singers a lot, but
like I do there are some of, I do listen to some of these
songs.
I know you're like, this is the most Weeby I've ever been.
But this is literally like one of the only Weeby's stuff
I've done.
I do.
This is the most weepy you've ever seen me.
All right, let's see if I can...
Dude.
Oh, they do!
Okay, there it is.
Oh my god.
Yay!
This Atomy girl is a weep.
All right, now I Guys, now, we can, I, you know, I was
supposed to buy one song today.
They're like, just remember to buy, buy a song.
It was like, I'll buy 20.
Wait, dude, what's Cover Shop?
Uh, oh, oh, is this a,
what do I want?
Yeah, give me your whole inventory.
Wait, they have a bad apple?
What's it called?
I'm just gonna call, I'm just gonna type.
Apple.
Is it ring?
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
Now, guys, if you guys want to play with me right now, we're
going to do it.
We're finally going to do it, guys.
It only took two hours.
Guys, it only took two hours.
I'm done shopping.
I'm finally done shopping, guys.
less.
Okay, there's music shop.
There's a shopping mall.
Wait, there's a shopping mall.
Wait, I can shop in a shopping mall.
Who would have thought?
I can...
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
I have...
Alright, you're gonna...
Ooh.
You're gonna wear...
Ooh, I should have liked this one more.
Wait, are you Are you wearing it now?
Well, you're not wearing it.
How do I make you wear this?
Please wear this outfit.
Oh, I have to create it.
Oh, yeah, no.
I'm not wasting it on you.
You're...
I know you're both equal.
I love you both equally, but I'm using it on rent.
I love them both equally.
Oh, wait.
This is hard to choose.
I like this or this.
They're both so cute.
Oh, that's so cute.
The little patches, too, and the paint splat.
I think I want to get an outfit with the paint splatters and
stuff.
I think that's one of my favorite, like, aesthetics.
Like the spray paint.
Or not just spray paint or paint splatters.
It's so cute.
But then she's so cute on this one too.
Okay, I'm going to get that one.
I'll craft this.
Because I can only craft two anyway.
So, alright.
What does Kairi do have?
Yeah, whatever.
I want Miku.
Oh, they can match!
Oh!
Okay, that's cute.
Okay, I'm going to put her.
Wait.
I'm going to put an Alice.
Oh.
I had an Alice or I'm going to do this.
This one's cute.
all right i'm gonna use my money all right nice okay i don't
have any money left all right okay now all right now guys
guys i'm ready all right how do i do okay guys if you guys
want to play with me please feel free to click like on the
link pinned in the chat or the exclamation point miku and
download the game and then we'll do a couple of songs
together all right let's see i'm gonna figure out how to do
this what's this billboard oh i get to have more all right
I'm trying to remember how to do this Oh, co-op show
Tournament shows with other players Alright guys Wait What
do I Uh Uh Was a key Oh here I'm generating remote
I wouldn't Okay next one We're all picking remote control
you have no friends not yet not yet in this game can you
give people stuff if i start if like as like um is there
like a uh is there like a uh reason to have friends in this
i'm bad is there is there a reason to have friends in this
game Don't you start?
That sounded so sad.
Wild.
Oh shit!
That's okay.
My team will carry me.
I'm doing so
good.
I don't know this song I actually never This is the first
time I've heard it
Guys I think I could do hard I said as I broke my combo
Am I winning
That said good right
I'm doing so good I'm like a prodigy I'm natural
I feel like I like You know like those people that type with
one hand That's me right Like uh Oh shit You know those
people that like When they're typing You know like Like with
the fingers That's me right now with this game
Because I have like a little stand for my iPad Yeah Yeah I'm
a little stabber.
I feel like I'm typing with what I'm typing it with my one
finger like with my fingers And so like you know, it's like
you know, you know what I'm talking about You know, like one
by one How do you know what I'm talking about like typing a
one by oh my god, guys I did it.
I knew I could do this We're so I I definitely carried That
was You're not even on my team Guys I definitely carry that
For sure I know, thank you Bye
I did contribute like 99% of the score there I
wait do I have to create new room every time all right so
I'll create a new room I want everyone to have a chance so
guys if you haven't downloaded the game yet feel free to
download now because I'm gonna make a new room every time
all right just so like everyone has a chance to play with me
guys we all select remote control five seven eight seven two
I don't even know why I even put it up here.
You guys are just, you guys just come in here before I
finish typing the letters.
Like, yeah, he's already here.
I don't even have to, all right.
Guys, everyone, remote control.
I, Dino!
I swear to God, Dino.
Dino!
He won the gotcha.
But Mark that guy.
Toe.
Yeah, toe.
The screen is, I got one guy.
One to 25% in a title leaves.
My bad.
Well, it's too late.
We gotta commit to it.
Say it like this, or you guys.
It's too late.
We have to commit to it now.
Yeah.
I don't know if you had one job.
Wait, this is not too hard.
I think it's the flicks.
It's the flicks.
The flicks throw me off.
Yeah, the flicks throw me off, man.
The taps are fine.
It's the flicks.
No, what is this?
okay oh my god what are these what are these buttons okay
thank god i bought an ipad i literally bought an ipad
yesterday just for the sponsor i don't think i could do this
on my phone i don't think i could do it on my tiny ass phone
No, I think I'm doing pretty well for first trying these
songs.
Not going to lie.
That's...
Yeah, okay.
I'm nailing it.
You have to say that.
It's my sponsor.
No, I have to use it for, like, writing stuff, too.
like autographs is much more convenient to do for like like
any like autograph merch or anything or like anything i have
to autograph and stuff i was like oh man might as well and i
could use as a business expense too yeah and anything if i
have any other like other sponsors that require that are
like mobile games or ipad games i could just use this uh all
right see you guys Look at that.
I'm such an... I think I...
Where am I?
Ha ha ha!
Guys, guys, I'm not last.
It's a good investment, yeah.
Guys, ha ha ha, not last.
Look at that.
He lost.
There's someone that's last and it's not me.
Yay!
Who is here?
Bye.
I got full combo, of course.
Okay.
Dabu can play expert joke.
Can he, though?
I did get more points than him.
I, by the way, guys, I am first trying, I'm first trying all
these songs.
So, um, I will say, I am first trying all these songs, guys.
I mean All I'm saying Doing pretty good
Anyway Okay On the practice How do I like access the actual
Oh is this just Oh it's the show Alright new code I'm not
even going to write the code Now I'm going to show it
Because like you guys get in so fast Alright New code 60562
Okay remote control this time guys remote control also if
you guys played already let other people have a chance to
play as well as well guys remote control so you had a chance
to be in a room let other dragoons have a chance to play
room despondent i can't have anything okay five three three
six four The moment I get to have remote control.
Alright, we're in.
By the way, if you got kicked out, if you got kicked out,
you have a chance to, you can join again.
Only if you played.
Just let other dragoons have a chance.
No one wanted to play remote control.
Guys, please.
Okay, this time for sure.
This time for sure.
Here we go.
We did it.
Oh my god, almost could cancel.
I was like, I'm done.
All right.
Bird you hard.
Yeah, master and expert.
Can you actually like play against other people or it's just
all teamwork?
All right, here we go.
This one's so, I love this song.
I love any song from Wonderful Opportunity.
Oh, is it ranked?
What the?
I should have went with the original.
This was meant to be a do it.
Click them after a moment.
Oh, I forgot to click.
The click always messes me up.
I don't know how people can talk about play rhythm games.
It's so hard.
I feel like usually they don't.
It's just full focus.
And then there's me.
I know what I am.
I don't even think people like when I watch rhythm gamers,
they don't even hum the song sometimes.
They just go lockful in.
Because I guess, you know, it has to like follow the rhythm.
I assume your voice isn't part of the rhythm.
You know?
It throws you off or something.
It's like when you're talking, you're not...
You're not talking to the beat.
I forgot how short the song is, too.
Yeah.
My note speed is too slow.
You want to...
Do you want me to go faster?
I'm doing normal speed.
Nice.
I carried.
What does increasing the note speed do?
Not normal.
Oh, I mean, it's fine for me.
Not last.
Those were my first time.
that sign not last baby bye
let's go I'm so good at this game I'm carrying every every
game I'm carrying right now I know it unlocks that total I
need five I have I'm not I'm not there our new room
Three, six, six, four, six.
All right.
What's the real?
Oh, my God.
Is that the real guy, you know?
Kind of the virtual singing?
Okay, here.
We have to be serving you.
We're not doing remote control again, guys.
Yes, I won.
Alright, let's try an expert.
How do I change the spacing?
Is it this?
What do I do?
Do I plus one, plus a little bit?
Oh, it's too late.
Alright.
Guys, I might crash out here, but I assume that you guys, if
I crash out, you'll carry this.
Alright, this is my first time on expert, guys.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, how bad can it be?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
Ah!
Oh, there you go.
I mean...
Ah!
Okay.
Everything's fine.
We're dying.
We're okay.
I might have been a little too overconfident.
I did it.
You're okay.
Follow the count.
Yay!
I did it.
Um, yeah.
I contributed.
I contributed to the score.
Yeah.
Yeah, but don't put your difficulty You're on, Medi.
Hard wasn't even...
You weren't even...
I bet...
Yeah, try and do that on my level.
Forever.
Yay!
Imagine almost beating me on hard mode.
Imagine that.
Oh, hey, they trust me more.
All right, all right, I need to look at the song.
Okay, we'll do the other, the Rin Servant of Evil.
I forgot what her one's.
I know Servant of Evil, but I forgot what the other one was.
All right, so we might, maybe we shouldn't go expert yet.
I don't think, I think maybe we're just not there yet.
Daughter of Evil, yes.
911.
911, 901.
Oh my God, I'm the first one here.
I'm the actual okay There you go Daughter of Evil
Da-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-nana
Alright Don't worry Daughter of Evil Let's go Alright I know
what I am Alright how do I do the speed again Oh I guess
we'll do that next time I don't know how much I have to add
how much should i add for the speed you're at 10 speed okay
10 speed we'll do it next time 10 speed
all right go about nine is fine okay we know where we're at
we know we know experts not for us we know
I recommend watching the videos for this song.
I love all the mad videos of it.
People even make mad videos anymore.
What combo did that break?
Oh my god, I don't even know.
It's that.
It's the hold one.
It's the fucking course it is.
I used to hold.
I don't hold.
I don't let it go in time.
I just want to tap.
Oh!
I know I didn't miss a single note.
No missed notes.
Oh, my MADs.
Look at that.
Cool combo again, guys.
Look at that full combo again, and I was not last look at
that Oh my god, get out of here get get out.
Oh My god, I'm so good at this game Okay, I need to look at
my song list because I need to know like There's my playlist
a playlist Okay I can create my own playlist if I create my
playlist does it show up in the custom room, too Guys, does
the playlist show up in the custom room?
Does that not be convenient?
Does it?
It's okay, no smug.
Someone has to be last.
And it's not me!
Okay.
That's right.
Good.
And that should be last.
Couldn't be me.
Okay, we're gonna do it.
I gotta do this.
What is that?
Oh, it's not the...
I thought it was another Persona.
You know, the classic one.
Oh my god, we got...
We gotta do Roki.
We gotta do this one, too.
We gotta...
We gotta do this too.
Oh my god, we're just listening to music at this point.
Viva, viva, happy.
Adrian.
It's just, we're just like, it's just, we're just listening
to music at this point.
We're,
this is just a music, like, it's just a music stream.
Let's dive in.
Wait, these are all original songs, right?
Are these original songs for the bands?
Yeah.
It's good.
That's why we're on Twitch, guys.
I don't know any of these, except for the wonderful...
Except for the wonderful opportunity.
Okay.
Oh, this one!
I know this one.
I actually don't.
Never mind.
I was thinking about the other moto song.
I was like, I know this one.
I don't actually.
She did not actually know it.
I actually don't know any of these.
I never heard them before.
I'm like, maybe I'll recognize one of them.
This is how any works.
Wait.
No.
I was like, maybe I listened long enough.
All these songs are- All these voices are blurring together.
Wait, do I know this one?
No, it sounds very...
No!
Where am I?
Wait.
Oh, it's here.
It sounds similar to the...
I think it's a Giga song.
It sounds very similar to one of them, but...
I can't remember which one it is.
It sounds very similar to it.
Wonderful opportunity.
Anything by wonderful opportunity.
I love their entire songs set list.
Oh my gosh.
How long am I going to be scrolling to it?
I was like, where am I?
A long while
All the voices All the voices Now I'm zooming
Hog roots All right Save It wouldn't be funny if I didn't
even save it.
We're buying all right.
Now we're ready.
We're ready now.
All right.
I don't think Black Rock Shooter is in here.
I wish it was.
Maybe they'll add in the future.
All right.
You guys ready?
Well, I would.
The songs.
I would recognize the notes.
And I would be like.
Oh, there's that's the song.
Oh, it is.
All right.
Okay.
I'm going to buy it.
What's it called?
Is it just Black Rock Shooter?
It's there.
Okay.
I'm gonna find it.
It was in the store!
Okay, I gotta look through the store again.
I love BlackRock Shooter.
There's my playlist.
Okay, playlist one.
Alright, guys.
I want to...
I want to do Roki.
Actually...
Let's do the shrimp song.
I swear to God.
Oh, I mean...
I don't have to buy it.
I'm fine with that.
I don't have to buy it, at least.
Oh.
Oh, no, okay.
Oh, okay, I guess I have to buy it now.
Well, fine.
I guess I'll buy it.
Fine.
I'll buy this time.
All right.
Okay.
Five, three, five, two, 7.
Awkward.
Fine.
I'm fine.
I'll buy the song.
That's fine.
I'm going to do this.
I want the shrimp.
Okay.
Let's see who wins the gotcha.
Let's see who wins the 50-50.
The 50-50.
Okay.
No.
I bought the song it didn't matter I want 9 right or was 8
I'll try 8 I don't remember who said like 8 or 9 was better
for me at the beginning
9 alright here we go because I know I said I was going to
react to stuff but like I I want to get through my playlist
oh yeah apparently bonus, 20% bonus crystals are your first
purchase of crystals from the web shop right now.
For the celebration of the 4.5 year anniversary.
Oh, it's so fast.
No!
Okay, I...
I...
I don't like how fast this is.
I'm actually doing worse.
Okay, I'm going back to my original speed.
It's too fast.
I like it when there's claustrophobia.
I like it when they're all bunched up together.
We all suffer together.
It's just too fast.
Black Rock Shooter?
I love Black Rock Shooter.
I know some people don't like the the remake When they added
like the All the new characters and stuff Because but I
personally enjoyed it The speed settings how it was too fast
what was default again is 6 default?
Yeah, I like the I like the original and the remake too Yeah
There was an anime there there's two Uh, there's two.
And the remake has, like, a...
The girl in the wheelchair.
She's so cool.
I have all the nundroids of the Black Rock Shooter figures.
Um...
And I have, like, the...
The scaled one of the Black Rock Shooter.
Thank you.
I know I did amazing.
I know.
Bye.
Little combo.
I know I carry.
I'm carrying all of them.
I know Yes, I'm very satisfied Not now Alright I'm gonna
Wait, actually I wanna I just realized I forgot to add Bad
Apple Oh wait, no, I did add Bad Apple Alright I can
challenge show Earn high school Increase the challenge level
special bonus get rewards oh no it's all right all right
let's go again we're gonna play all of these songs five
seven zero zero three i'm creating oh someone's gone okay we
want to do it after let's do we'll do it
Ah, we'll do this.
Or we'll do Bad Apple.
No, no, no, no.
Overdue King.
We have to be King.
Everyone's like, which one is she doing?
She keeps...
No!
That was none of the things I said.
That was none of the songs that I suggested.
I don't know the song.
I never heard of the song.
before this is the first time i've heard this song guys guys
that was none of the songs i requested dragoons i don't know
medicine this would be first time hearing it
i don't know i mean
All I'm seeing My shrimp song Was better Oh my god it's
flick I was like Why isn't it working
I think the shrimp song is better
Whoops It's the holes in the flicks.
Okay, I'm getting the hand of it.
Okay, I say as I broke my combo.
Yep, that's like I'm dropping my combos.
There we go.
We did it.
Yeah!
I don't know, I think...
Um...
Not my type of song, I will say.
I'm not first time hearing it, but like, a lot of the songs
I like are very like...
There's like a particular...
Like, a lot of like the virtual singer songs I like are very
particular, like...
Are very like...
Oh, what's the word?
Like there's certain style to it.
But I personally...
It's not my...
The song I would like listen to.
In general.
all right again now guys guys guys we're gonna pick my song
i never watched the music video i don't so like i've never
heard of this one before 46 469 nice okay guys i'm gonna say
it and then we're all gonna pick my song jockey bird king
king king oh if you guys
You had one job.
I said king.
That's not even...
I...
I could leave.
I couldn't leave.
Are you okay?
I could have left.
I should have left.
left.
I should have left the room until I get my song.
Um, I have control of the playlist.
It's my turn.
It's my, um, my, my iPhone is plugged into the car right
now.
We're picking my song.
We're supposed to be picking my songs.
That's the one that's plugged into the car right now.
That's on the Bluetooth.
All right, here we go.
What the fuck?
Oh, stupid holes.
Ah!
There you go.
I'm okay.
I'm dead.
You know what?
I'm surprised I survived that long.
There's just so many flicks.
Oh!
it's still going on the song doesn't end
look this is my first time on this song I just have to say
what
the fuck okay it's fine are you that's fine I'm just like
I'm dead anyway I'm not contributing to any score nice
strides the the off tune part like when like both of them
was like one side was a different beat to the other it was
crazy who chose this who was it
i'm i'm not last i mean i'll take that who was it i don't
even remember i literally don't even remember.
I got full combo, though.
Not last, guys.
Not last.
As always.
It's a real jokie, right?
Alright.
Now, okay.
24834.
You guys want to play with me right now?
You can download a game by clicking on the link pinned in my
chat.
Are you doing exclamation point Miko?
I'm doing co-op with all the dragoons.
Well, obviously not all, but like we're good.
Guys, we're going to pick king, guys.
Yeah, king.
Doki Bird Reels.
You already did this.
Guys, king.
That's it.
I'm leaving this room.
I can't leave.
Guys.
I win.
The real Doki Bird actually win.
Yeah, but guys, if you played already, let other dragoons
have a chance to play it.
They do not care.
I will turn this car around and do solos so I can get my
songs.
I will do that.
You know I will.
So I can play the songs I want to play.
Alright, this is a team effort, and some people are ranked
higher than others.
say who i won't say who it might surprise you it might
surprise you who that what the answer is
wonder who it could be who could it be yay king night side
night side
When will Joki do her king cover?
If I could ever even reach that note.
Thank you.
I'm pretty sure me humming this song is making me worse of a
player.
Oh shit, I'm- oh my god, my thing moved.
It threw me off.
I tapped too hard.
Ah!
Right side, right side.
I'm dead.
I moved, I've actually moved my iPad.
The angle's off now.
I think.
Okay, I forgot the sign, so yes.
I was like, it's over.
That's fine, I'm not contributing anyway.
I'm dead anyway.
There you go.
The iPad moved.
It, it, like, threw me up.
I tapped you hard.
I survived.
There you go.
We got my king.
I made it to the end.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Sorry, it moved again.
It keeps sliding.
I messed it up, guys.
As it keeps sliding.
All right, there we go.
Good.
Bye.
They trust me more now Oh, no, the angle's all off now Okay,
now, guys, guys Okay, now, bye, bye Okay, guys, bye bad
apple We're doing bad apple Actually, actually, wait, let me
decide Alright, what do we have now?
Let's see Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no No, no, no, no,
no, no
Let's do...
I don't know.
Bad apple, guys.
Actually, I'll commit.
Bad apple.
We're going to do bad apple, guys.
Wow, you guys...
I forgot to show you guys the room.
Alright, bad apple, everybody.
Nia.
Wait, who is this?
guys guys I still won let's go wait I joined a random public
room and I made them oh did I join a public room I joined a
public room I made them play my song I didn't I didn't even
make a room I was like I mean you're gonna play my song.
I was like, wow, everybody, whoops, I got too excited.
And I won.
Yeah, that's right.
You guys are going to play my song now.
That's thinking, right?
I'm like the only baby in this public room, too.
You're going to be, who's this person in on baby mode?
No!
I was trying to lock in.
So I pressed the I was trying to press them!
I wanted to press them to be like, look, the baby's doing
her job.
In the public room.
I was actually trying to lock it.
That was doing so well too.
I was like, look at me, yes!
I'm contributing!
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, I contributed.
I didn't know.
Now I'm so embarrassed.
I was trying to impress all the cool adults in the room.
That's why I'm so locked in.
You can tell I have one singing I wasn't having.
And anything, I was like, it's, I'm going to look so cool.
Look at me.
Oh, he disconnected.
They left.
I think.
Oh, wow.
Thanks, guys.
Let's do it, everybody!
You think...
Guys...
Do you think they think I'm cool?
Oh my god.
Do you think...
I want to think I'm cool now.
Ronald Doki, you don't do that for me.
for us guys guys i know i don't need to impress you guys
because you know you're already impressed
i know you're already impressed or like already
guys they're not who is sweet but they don't know that all
right here at one four nine eight that's the new one i'm
impressed all right number one dokey hated i swear to god if
you don't pick my song it's spoken like a true true dokey
hated let's do let's do a happy song let's do let's do happy
number one dokey hated does not want happy.
Oh, it's too bad!
Another reason to hate me.
One more reason to hate me.
Nice.
And I did it again.
Alright.
They're like, play a few songs.
I'm like, I'm playing a lot of songs.
It's fun, though.
I just, like, listen to all the, like, going back to Nostal,
like, memory lane and nostalgia.
Um...
Memory lane and nostalgia of all these songs.
It's fun to be like, why I know these songs?
It's been so long.
It's fun to just listen to it.
This is weird.
I should want to do a cover of this song.
This is...
I don't know, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Stop!
It's one of my favorites.
I love this time.
This time makes me happy.
Meemah, meemah, happy.
No, no, no.
It's one of my favorite ones.
Yeah, that reminded me of the Lucky Star song, too.
But, oh, no.
No.
Where is it?
Too cool.
That's right.
What's the hat have?
Nice to meet you, Sinkus.
back here.
Uh-huh.
This is my.
It's all right.
This says one.
Why is there one, two, three, five in what context?
Huh?
Alright.
That's funny.
One.
I don't I don't think there is one.
What is it?
I don't think there is a six in here.
It's just, it stops at five.
They knew where to stop at.
Hello!
One and a half stage.
Is that the Hasunai Miku colorful stage?
Thank you!
Oh my God!
Is that the real Hasunai Miku colorful stage, guys?
The real one!
The Miku color- Miku Hatsune, colorful stage!
Sorry, I know Miku on a first name basis.
So I always, you know, it always throws me off when I caught
the color by her full name.
Um, is- is the- no, no, I- after this!
I just wanna keep- I'm sorry, I know.
I said after this, I'm just getting- I'm just too into this
right now.
I have to listen to all the songs.
all right let's do okay now we do Roki Roki guys Roki I'm
locked in right now I swear to God a a Ron I swear to God a
Ron oh I win nice I know this has a 50 50 but seems like a
hundred percent to me.
Sorry, we're too busy jamming.
I don't.
I swear to God, Raren, you better get in here.
That's it.
I will listen to Roki then.
That's it!
If you, if I, if we can't have Roki, I will have Roki.
Let's see what you did, chat.
Yeah, but I don't know.
But, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but,
but, but, but, but, but, but, but, who am I to him?
Shit!
I'm sorry!
It caught me off guard!
Where's my Miku?
But what you did, Kaito!
You make me break my combo!
This is your fault.
This is his fault.
He's breaking my combos.
He threw me off my groove.
Nice Yay
Every time it cuts to Kaido It kills the Kaomo It was his
fault guys
It's okay At least I didn't die I think he's part of the
team Excuse me This is a girl band Oh, it's because he's on
my team, so they added him in.
He's the combo breaker.
Is that why?
That actually makes more sense.
I was like, that's why he's always there.
I just realized that's why he's always there.
I thought he'd be like outside the window.
I even realized that's the reason.
All right, all right, now we can...
make another room.
I got my Rokie out.
Alright, 39431, guys.
Hey, Ron.
Alright, we're gonna do Drop Pop Candy.
Drop Pop Candy.
I swear to God.
How do I leave?
How do I disconnect?
I plug on you?
Oh, no.
My iPad ran Get out of the battery.
Close the game.
I just closed the game.
I never heard of this song before.
From Beat Mario.
Oh, it's from Beat Mario.
I recognize that name.
Oh, I'm one, two.
Oh, it's like Toho.
E-ming, E-ming.
There you go.
You can tell like I'm not even...
There we go.
I like the call response.
Is that George Washington?
Or Mozart?
Who's that?
Oops.
Was that Mozart?
She's doing my virtual singing.
I wonder who's his, Oshi.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
I don't know.
Yay!
I
think he's gone.
Yeah, I'm contributing with my combos.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I have 51 combo, almost as much as my teammates.
Yeah, that was me.
57 combo.
I know it was pretty high.
It was.
I know.
It was pretty high.
good don't hurt your back don't worry guys I won't make you
guys look too bad against me okay all right we'll do okay we
gotta do the other stuff so we'll do one more song two more
songs we'll do two more songs actually how many songs I have
left sorry where's my playlist my playlist okay we have to
drop pop candy i will plug if we don't get drop pop candy
guys i will plug if we don't get drop pop candy and then and
then and then you can't even play 369 nice 39 okay
oh yes drop pop candy guys that's right that's right dino
dino that's all about dino I swear to god nice alright I win
see all I have to do is threaten them We get the right song
or I get the right song.
Exactly.
We get the right song or I get the right song, guys.
That's all it takes, so easy.
It's gotta make a little thread.
All right, here we go.
and then okay we'll do two more after that we'll do me
actually do we end on dune or miku i feel like we should end
on miku so we'll do dune and then miku all right for the
last two songs if you haven't played uh oh my god okay i'll
talk about this later i didn't think i see so many notes on
the screen
i was not expecting all these notes
The flicks threw me up.
Oh, it's the flicks.
Oh, this one's fast.
Oh, my God.
This one's fast.
I have to lock in for this.
This is so fast.
Oh, my God.
I'm not dead, though.
Oh.
I swear they think.
throw in a flicks anywhere.
Oh, I didn't die.
I'm still alive.
Oh my god.
That one was hard.
I was like ready to talk.
I was like, I cannot say anything.
Okay.
The next two songs.
If you've already played with me, guys, let other drag
wounds have a chance, guys.
Okay.
Not last.
There had to be one and it's not me as again look at that
look at that wasn't me all right if you guys have i guess
already played with me let other dragoons have a chat
because we're doing two last songs or any of them would meet
you but we're gonna do do next all right one six eight zero
six guys one six eight zero six
one six eight zero six Let the other dragons have a chance
to play
What was I gonna do Dune that guys dude I will plug if I
don't get my song I will leave and then we play Dune solo
can't have nice things
I will leave It's my song or no song
all right here we go i love sand planet i love the music
video sand planet it's so pretty the animation is so good
also i didn't expect to do such a long stream today for
hatsune miku colorful stage but i got a little i got just a
little bit too invested i want to see your sec guy worlds
but it's like i don't know how long the tutorial is for sec
guy It's the holds!
I don't want to let it go in time.
This goddamn trap.
Give me that drop, give me that drop.
It's getting here.
Drop it's getting closer.
All right, there you go.
I got it in my system.
Yeah!
Oh, I love that drop part.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I did do...
I did do my Sakai earlier.
I did do it.
But then, like...
Oh, nice!
Yay!
There was, like, like, I think I got to, like, three...
I got to like three of it okay where are we all right let's
I got to three of them it's like a very long tutorial I
wanted to visit other people's worlds and I got distracted
with the gotcha part all right all right everybody please
leave my world all right everyone please leave and then they
gave me money and then I went into gotcha and they left and
they gave me money I was like alright bye guys I'm gonna go
roll now
party's over
yeah and then they judged my room they're like Are you not
done decorating?
And I was like, I'm done decorating.
What do you mean?
Yay!
Even though they judged my room.
I guess you skipped through it at the top, right?
You know, I could.
Because they have been, they have been like judging me a
lot.
Every time they come in, they're like, is this really your
world?
I'm like, I was just born like five minutes ago.
Like, what do you want from me?
I learned how to walk like five minutes ago.
Yes, this is my world.
Yeah, girl, you live like this.
Yes, I do live like this.
That's my actual room.
My room has one bed, one bed, one dresser that's just full
of socks.
And that's it.
I have nothing on my walls.
And in the corner is one giant cardboard box filled with
clothes I didn't unpack.
That is my room.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, nice.
I got more items.
Oh!
Right now they're here.
Oh, hello, Ren!
My favorite virtual singer.
Wait, since Hatsune, since the Hatsune Miku colorful stages
here, do we have a dev, a dev room that I could visit?
Let's judge a dev helper's room.
Do you know any staff's room on top of your head?
Let's judge their room.
They must have everything unlocked.
You know?
I want to, let's visit, let's visit the Hatsune Miku
Colorful Stages room.
If I'm gonna get judged, I shall now judge them.
Let's go.
Okay, we'll speed run this.
Also, while we're doing this, we're gonna do one last shot.
So feel free to download the game pinned.
It is free, by the way.
is free so you can play this right now with me after this
part and we're gonna do one last song we're doing a miku
miku miku uh and it is your last chance to play with me for
the very last song so make sure to download the game for
them oh are they famous i mean they should be they're like
are you gonna watch my stream will you watch my stream oh
yeah miku miku
That's me, I follow for follow.
Follow for follow?
Jump jump?
All right.
Hi.
Oh my gosh, I'm in front of Li Haruka.
Yeah, I do.
Oh
my giving me a tour.
That's everything.
I have a house.
I have a bench on the right.
And then two tires.
Welcome to my crib.
Hatsune Miku.
And I thought to your second guy could be connected like
this.
I was surprised at the first, but now I hope we can be good
friends.
Oh my god, guys.
Now I'm friends with two Miku's.
Are you jealous?
Oh, okay.
That's their second guy.
Okay, we're almost there.
Let's start at you showing up all of a sudden.
Wait, why do you seem more nervous and surprised?
You're not sure what to say?
Just treat me how you and anyone else.
I hope we can get along.
Yeah, I'm friends with two Nikus.
Oh, how many doors are we missing?
How many more?
How many doors are we missing?
Oh, Minori.
Oh, Minori!
Do we just have one last one left?
Is Leo need the last one?
I don't know how many I've had visited my crib.
I've lost count.
This is the third one.
Actually, I didn't lose count.
I'll have to make a garden now.
Guys, we might have to skip the second and last one.
I think I have two more left, right?
It's this.
It's, uh, well, they want fences.
Okay, and garden.
Okay, that's a lot of stuff that they want.
Uh, the other groups just wanted, like, two things.
Different materials in each one.
area.
Did they not give me stuff?
Harvest by... Okay, I need petals.
Okay.
Oh, that's a lot.
Okay, we're just gonna grab plants here.
Okay, plant.
Plant.
The rise and grind.
Is that enough?
They have enough.
Alright, that should be enough.
Oh, five.
Okay, I can't count.
Now that's enough.
All right, we're good.
I'm leaving now.
Goodbye, everybody.
Going back to my house.
Okay, now I need to build dirt paths.
Yeah, I got this.
I'm building.
And then I'll just build one fence.
Who's gonna, you know, just want one.
I assume like I'll build one It's a path Where will it lead
They didn't say How much they want I put in front of my
house Oh I thought I could If I could lock myself in Or
build a barrier Please do not Please believe
It's because I I've built one.
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
Is it because I build one?
Okay.
I might need two.
I might need more than one.
The game was like, you should have built more than one.
Alright, there we go.
Do my, did my fingerprints burned off while playing?
Did I like die or something?
Like they don't feel a pulse anymore?
What happened?
Like, am I like a ghost?
Like where's my finger?
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
Yes, I'll end it.
Oh my god, I needed more.
Apparently, I needed more guys.
Cancel.
Guys, we need more than four.
Give me a sec.
Who would have thought?
Do I need more fences too?
Did my skin grow so thick it became a glove?
Like, what happened?
Okay.
There we go.
Place.
I...
We just don't know how to trace.
There we go.
Guys, don't worry, I can do this.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Guys, I still need one more.
For some reason.
Can I build join a tutorial?
How much more do you...
I'll build one more just in case.
I actually had enough.
Oh, I did.
Okay.
There we go.
Tokey, please.
I did it!
I built 14.
I'm so proud of myself.
Alright, we just need fences now.
how many do we need oh two okay that's thank god okay that's
good where did my fence go where's my fence where
am i supposed to put it
yes where did my fence go i don't understand
oh Oh!
I am an adult.
I don't have...
Do I not have fences again?
That's a lot of fences.
Okay, I need to create more fences, guys.
I need to create more fences.
Don't worry.
We will see the staffs.
We're gonna see the staffs thing soon.
I just gotta start building fences.
Okay.
I did it.
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
Baby's first.
Oh, no, no, don't worry.
I'm drawing the fence.
Slowly but surely.
Yes.
Come on.
You're almost there.
Do I not have fences?
I don't have enough.
I don't have enough fences.
Oh my gosh, where do I where do I find where do I find okay
in the fledging fields Where is it?
I don't even oh, it's in here.
I need to find nails Where do they put nails?
Oh, it's in the toolbox.
Oh, who's leaving all these toolboxes?
Guys, we will react soon I'm just trying to find toolboxes
I got ore though Wild grown toolboxes Don't you hate it When
When there's so many When you have a toolbox infestation On
your local woods Don't you hate that guys?
And then you have to call like the exterminator To get rid
of all of these All these toolboxes growing in your garden
I don't grinds my gears.
I can only build three more.
So, I know.
Like, it's a problem.
No.
There we go.
Oh my god, we did it.
oh my god we did it we failed fences wait wait what am i
missing i need two okay two garden beds okay it's fine i
have enough materials for one more
okay what else am i even missing in my house all right i'm
sorry we're just gonna we're just gonna oh wait i did
everything Are you guys not happy?
Oh, they're gonna leave now.
Goodbye.
Yay!
It's my power.
Definitely my feelings.
Yeah, we'll see that.
With a power of friendship, we did it.
Alright, let's skip.
The fences took up too much time.
We're just... Sorry, you don't get dialogue anymore.
The fences took too much time.
Okay, what am I missing?
Okay.
I can't even find that.
I need a petal.
Colorful Canyon.
I can't even...
I can't even go...
There's no way.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright, it's fine.
Hello, everybody.
I'm sorry.
We gotta...
Oh yeah, I'll talk to you though.
Hey there, I'm Len.
I see my apartment right now.
Also, DJ.
Actually, Ryan is in here right now.
I think someone ate the pudding.
She put the fridge, so she's out looking for...
Alright, goodbye.
Alright.
Rano, it's time.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
Toya!
I'm taking away your speaking privileges now.
We ran out of time.
It's okay.
I will never run out of time for Leo, though.
Guys, it's okay, guys.
Someone had to get the short end of the stick,
unfortunately.
It's okay.
Wait, what?
Uh, change your background music.
Oh, if only I read how to do that guys oh man if only if
only i know how to do that okay we need one more plastic
okay do i go to get plastic i don't have to find plastic is
it also in the toolbox oh it is all
And I'm like, oh no.
Alright, now I can build it.
It's okay.
All the budget went to Leonean.
Someone had to get cut.
And I can put that down.
Beautiful.
Did I have a record?
Does anyone have a record?
I have to make that too.
wait what we're not have one oh my god if only i read oh a
fledging field oh one of them must have told me one of them
if i did it oh there it is if i didn't skip the talk one of
them would have told me all right
there you go got it oh it's ready steady all right i'll
select that gem
yeah yeah i did that's me
wait they caught me off guard I was trying to jam they
caught me off guard guys I'm sorry we got too busy jamming I
forgot we cut there we cut their budget all right goodbye
all right now Wow!
Alright.
You slide dog, you had me jamming.
Our leonid.
So all the budget went to them, so they get speaking
privileges.
Hey yo!
Nani?
...
My girl
Everybody's so cute.
That's me.
Yeah, talk to me as they had an interaction in front of me.
Hello, guys.
Do you guys like my crib?
I don't know what will they make me make.
Hey, Chica.
Yeah, Chica.
Yeah, I'm here with Leonido, How are you?
I know, right?
Thank you.
It's my world.
No, it's fine.
That's like, I'm curious, does Hatsune Miku colorful stage?
Is it like all just, is it all Japanese dubbing?
Or do they have like English dub too?
I assume it's all Japanese, right?
of like the music and stuff.
That truck.
I'm curious about that.
I'll leave you for last, Miku.
No, no.
You're my chosen ones.
We all get to choose our favorite band and I choose you
guys.
In fact, the others barged in.
You guys were invited.
If anything, We don't need it.
We're the only groups that had the invitation.
The other groups decided to show up.
Hello, Luca.
You're the one here?
Oh, you're enjoying several more now.
Yeah, what's wrong with me being the only one here?
How do we try for the longer then?
Uh, can you tell me about the set guy?
So the set guy has only just created.
Really?
Your feelings turn into materials you can build things with?
Yeah.
the Sakai your own?
That's kind of interesting.
It is!
I don't know, it's pretty cool.
Do you have your autograph?
Oh, that's cute!
Because it's based off of like their theme.
Who's the most popular group?
And or do they all have like an equal sort of fan base?
It was technically the fan favorite and colorful stage.
Oh, Nightcourt is the most popular.
It's not Leonine!
I thought Leonine was the most popular.
I guess I gotta change meta.
I'm a sheep.
I guess...
Guys, my favorite is actually nightcord.
Leo is least popular.
People don't night girl.
Okay, to be fair, nightcord is girl band too.
Nightcord is a girl band.
Name one member from nightcord.
Ah, Hatsune Miku.
Checkmate Damn, he got you there But
Can anyone see the stars?
Oh, it's the I can fix her.
Okay, I get it now.
I get it.
I thought it would be Nolita Nii.
That was the most popular.
I did not read that right.
I don't know.
I love Girl Bens.
So now I'm sad.
I'm a sucker for Girl Bens.
What do I need?
I don't have enough stars.
Okay, I need to get a fragment.
Oh, I found it.
So convenient.
There's the X Machina right there.
I guess sad songs.
Sad songs is like the emo songs.
I mean, you can be a...
You can have emo songs in the girl band.
Wouldn't it be funny if I placed a telescope, like, behind
the house?
Wait, I can still do that.
I can now.
Now they're all going to use it.
And I placed it against the wall.
That's true.
A lot of the classic songs do have, like, super edgy ones.
Like the Alice song.
some stargazing oh my gosh oh my gosh is this like a meteor
strike on it guys there's a bit too many guys when the sky
has too many stars falling that's not a good sign all those
comets are gonna hit the earth they're gonna hit they're
gonna hit my senkai
where are they falling it's a meteor shower isn't it usually
fall like shooting stars
I think I like Leo needs uh Miku design the most out of all
the Miku designs here
and meteor air strike Yeah.
It's beautiful.
All right, it's time.
Please leave.
Go back home guys Go back home
Oh, hey Miku I'm just so close to the finish line.
I just really want to see see the devs place
Thank you Miku skip the end I'm sorry I just we're so close
look there were budget cuts guys there were there were
budget cuts we had to skip it I mean you skip my code look
we're friends she understands i just want to see i want to
see the house also anyone write down the the code because i
didn't i didn't write the code guys
i thought that i was just like oh it's okay i forgot like
you can't scroll up if after a certain like after you
received an X amount of messages on chat.
So I might have forgotten to copy it.
Does anyone copy the code?
The staff's house from the Hatsune Miku colorful sage.
Wait, why are they in my...
Okay.
Hello.
Alright, how do I visit?
Thank you staff all right now i go to your house all right
all right uh two four three nine nine three eight nine one
seven eight zero six 1-0.
They got that.
Oh, Eugene's my sick guy.
Alright, let's visit.
I don't know.
It's gonna be hard to beat my house.
My house was pretty cool.
Alright, Eugene.
Alright, and we're loading in.
Okay, can't be as cool as my house.
Can't be as cool Can't be as cool as my You remodeled Oh my
god Alright But still it can't be as cool as my house That's
sick Oh my god There's swings Wait how do I Yeah my turn get
it You like kick them out Oh wait That's cute.
Yeah, it can be as cool.
Guys.
Oh my god, you have an arcade?
Now, can I have this?
Now this is my house.
Oh, I can.
Guys, you didn't see that.
Guys, I did not.
I did not accidentally in it.
Dogs.
My dogs.
sitting.
That was my dog sitting.
What?
They were sending me dad updates.
Guys, please.
I don't get in trouble.
They were sending me dog updates.
What?
No one saw anything.
You guys want to see a live dad update?
No, I shouldn't.
Okay.
Wait.
You actually talked?
Oh, I can.
Yo.
Oh, my God.
I can't.
Wait.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's so cute.
That is so cute.
What's this?
Oh, wait, that's where you change clothes.
Alright, I can wash my hands.
Oh, wait, you can play the piano?
Did I write the VOD channel?
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
Definitely gonna get it.
You have three floors?
See, this is staff privilege.
We live in a society.
We truly live in a society.
Oh my god, I can't leave because...
Please!
I can't leave.
She's blocking her door.
They're blocking the door.
I can't leave.
I can't.
Help.
Oh my god.
I accidentally talked to her.
Oh.
Okay, it's right here.
I see it now.
I see it.
Sorry, I see it now.
It's the switch.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
Oh, I can play the guitar.
I can play the guitar.
Oh, that's me playing the guitar.
I thought I was gonna pick it up.
My bed.
This is my house now.
Alright.
I see.
And like, when you mark your territory with my body, my
coach.
Guys, my house is pretty cool, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Are you guys impressed?
I built this.
I invited Eugene over to look at my house.
I know!
Guys, you guys think my house is cool?
this so when i designed this sec guy i wanted to have like a
little like like fun hangout session but like gotta go oh
yeah you should have to leave my sec guy guys but like yeah
i wanted to build this as like a little reminiscent of of
like the of like a playground you know and then um and then
obviously you know you have to work out next yeah i have to
work out you gotta get your reps in And I want like a little
miniature...
A little miniature arcade area.
So everyone who visits my Sekai can like, you know, have
some leisure times and everything.
Anyway, um...
Thanks for visiting my Sekai staff.
I really appreciate it.
I hope you like it.
Alright, and this is staff's...
This is staff's Sekai's.
So I'm visiting his Sekai now.
Guys, I know it's not as good as the one I have.
I know, I know.
But, like, with enough time, staff, with enough time, it
could be just as cool as mine.
With enough time.
I'll give you a tip.
I feel like you should maybe, you know, move this bench and
these tires a little further away because it's like, you
know, and then maybe change the road a little bit.
I feel like, you know, the brown dirt path, it just doesn't
really...
Not really classy enough, but, you know, one day you'll be
just as good as mine.
Let's get it.
You know, the pro tip as a professional tech guy builder.
All right, one last song, guys.
One last song.
For everyone that has downloaded it.
I might have to do only, I might have to react to one, one
showcase today.
I did not.
I'm sorry, I got way too caught up.
But thank you.
Thank you.
How's the name Miku?
I have to change the bed now.
Yeah, I know, because my bed looks so cool.
Am I sick guy?
Our last song.
We're gonna do the Miku, Miku, Uliu.
Thank you for showing us your...
Sorry, thank you for letting me show you my sick guy.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for visiting.
Visiting it.
Sasson.
This is the last call.
It's it.
I am out.
But thank you.
Alright, here's the code.
39265.
Oh.
All the gamers out.
And then they're sleepy.
Alright, where is it?
There we go.
Me too.
All right, last song.
I was like, can I do?
I don't think I could do hard.
Or expert.
No.
All right.
One more time.
I'm sorry, guys.
Five, seven, three.
1-0.
It got denied.
Our last song.
571-3-0.
Oh, I think they're all bad.
Oh, wait, no.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye, Sleepy.
Sleepy.
No, Sleepy.
Sleepy got replaced.
Goodbye.
You could be there.
You could play the song in spirit.
Alright, here we go.
Rest in peace, sleepy.
Maybe it was the sleepy diff.
Oh, the room didn't get disbanded, sleepy.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I just twisted the knife.
I'm sorry, sleepy.
Bro, they're already dead.
Dead turkey.
No!
Miku, Miku, oh yeah.
When
did I break the combo?
Oh, that's when.
Meeku, meeku, meeku, meeku, meeku.
I don't even know when it's when I'm breaking it I feel like
I'm tapping it
okay that I could see that one
I did it guys okay other people broke their combos guys
other people broke their combos too It's not just me, guys.
Oh, we did it.
Yay!
Did you see that?
It says I'm a superstar.
Guys, did you see it?
Oh, my God.
Do me thank you for the raid.
Oh, but I was literally just playing the meeku meeku meeku i
was literally just playing that song okay well i guess we'll
do one more song we do have another stuff other more another
here comes the dude i just say that someone someone gave the
bitties but we had a great stream what are you guys doing
this um this was originally supposed to be like two hours
but it's not four hours now i got a little too invested.
But we do have something else after this.
But we'll do one more.
Alright, Duberts.
You guys can request a sign.
What sign do you guys want?
You know what?
I'll pull.
I'll do a pull for you guys too.
I have enough.
We'll do one pull.
I think we got everybody.
We want it.
Just for you guys.
I'll do one pull.
One more sign.
Do the request a sign.
Oh, I didn't even check.
I don't have anybody new.
I got you.
All right.
Unfortunately, we didn't get any.
We didn't get any.
Oh, meltdown?
Melt?
Do I have melt?
All right.
Someone.
You guys better pick melt.
Oh, we just did bad apple.
We'll do it again.
Alright.
3, 2, 1, 6, 9.
We don't do bad apple again.
You know what?
Let's do it.
We'll do bad apple again.
Oh, it's A-A-Ron.
We run it back.
We're running it back for Juby.
Okay, where's bad apple?
Oh.
All right, here we go.
That's for Doobie and the Dewbirds.
The hardest difficulty?
Yeah, hard is the one the hardest.
I know.
I know there's, like, something after hard, but, like, it
was a little glitch.
But hard's the hardest difficulty.
I know.
I'm a real gamer.
Alright, here we go.
This is for Doobie and the Duberts.
And the Doobies.
Um, yeah.
I didn't drop a combo yet.
Yeah.
I'm gaming.
Yeah, I didn't drop a combo yet.
I'm just carrying my team right now.
On my back.
No need to applaud.
Oh my god!
Full combo!
Lag?
God, I can't believe that lag there, guys.
God, network error.
God, please.
I'm so good at this game.
No, no, no, no, no, no No, no, no, no No, no, no, no, no
But that didn't drop a single combo.
Perfect combo.
Ah, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
I know.
Look at that.
Not last.
Maybe even first.
Yeah, sorry, my phone combo.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I know it says superstar on AA-ROM, but the screen is
a little bugged.
It was supposed to be on me, but because of that little lag,
it pushed the superstar.
It's just a graphical issue, guys.
They actually swapped my score with AA-ROM.
By the way.
It's true.
Yep.
All me.
Sorry, yes.
I know.
It's...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I'm so embarrassed.
I can't believe they swapped my score.
All right.
Yay.
Oh, I got a new record, too.
Oh, my gosh.
But, yeah.
We set more to go, but...
sponsor portion is going to be ending very soon.
Only the real gamer.
You have the gamer glasses.
You can see my full combo.
before we end the sponsored portion, we do have more of it.
We're going to react to.
We're going to choose one showcase to react today because I
went a little over I went just a little bit over time.
Like just a little bit.
You know, like two hours over time.
But we'll react to the rest another day might be maybe on
Thursday um but huge shout out and thank you to Sega and
Hatsune Miku colorful stage for sponsoring today's stream I
really appreciate uh them sponsoring today's stream letting
me it's been 4.5 year anniversary it's the 4.5 year
anniversary uh for uh for Hatsune Miku for Hatsune Miku
colorful stage and it was really fun to come back to the
game it's been like I said The last time I played it was
when it first came out, so it was really nice to see all the
new things and just go back to memory lane with all the
songs and everything, all the ritual singer songs, like all,
and it was really fun.
And also to check out the new Porter Rock Porter Robinson
collab song with, um, and just all the new anniversary
stuff.
You have a lot of new anniversary freebies right now.
You are, if you want to join in, download it as a free game.
So remember to download, activate a couple of stage with the
link pinned in the chat or use exclamation point Miko.
and download it yourself and to play it out.
If you like rhythm games or you like going through memory
lane and listening to all these old classics, this is the
time to do it now because there's a lot of freebies right
now for like polls and stuff.
What else?
Like I said, there are some social campaigns too and you
guys can follow their TikTok.
TikTok.com, colorful, underscore, stage, underscore EN or
you can Google that.
Um, and yeah, so they haven't, Corey Robinson has a new
song.
Um, it's called Cheerleader.
You know what's funny?
Um, they were like, even like the devs were like, you should
do 9 or 10 for the speed.
And I was like, no.
Maybe, let's do, let's end it with one.
I don't know where you said, end it with Cheerleader, you
know, because it is the new song.
I'll try the 10 speed.
You know what?
I'll try it.
That's the recommended speed.
all right it is the recommended speed anyway how do i do it
because i did it all right we're gonna try it said
recommended speed is nine or ten i'm gonna try this out
we'll see how this goes we're gonna um but it's the part of
robinson's collab song which is this the costume for the
Virtual Avatar and MySekai, the 4.5 anniversary version
costume, double rates for four-star gotcha, and 4.5
anniversary bundles in store, and the UGC campaign on
social.
There's so many things.
All right, here we go.
Let's go.
We ended on the...
We ended on 10 speed.
This is my first time on 10 speed.
Let's see how this goes.
This is the new side that they added just for the
anniversary.
We'll see how...
Let's see.
Ready?
But we'll do one pull for the road.
One last pull.
We just have enough.
And it's all yellow.
We don't deserve it.
All right, we got Saki.
This.
If you guys want to try the game out, like I said, you can
download it as a free game.
Um, and you like rhythm beams, this is like, you know, one
of the best rhythm games out there.
Uh, so, um, to be fair, I haven't played a lot of them, but,
but out of all the ones I've played so far.
Uh, feel free to click the link pinned in the chat.
It is a free game that you can download.
Um, and it's fun.
It was fun.
I literally went over time by a lot because I was enjoying
myself.
I was enjoying myself playing the game with you guys.
too.
Hey, guys.
Good shout out and thank you again.
Alright.
Let us...
Oh, that's not it.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Say bye, dude.
Hatsune Miku.
Colorful stage, guys.
Bye.
I'll still be here.
We're saying goodbye to the game.
Not me.
I'll still be here.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
Goodbye, game.
Alright.
all right let me unplug this now so i don't accidentally
dream the it didn't charge my i bought like a little adapter
but it didn't charge my i don't know if it doesn't work when
i'm like doing a when i'm doing game capture all right you
shout out again to sega i literally bought I bought a new
iPad with the money I got for this uh so I can play this
game so I could so it could be under a business expense I
needed I needed an iPad I didn't have an iPad I really did
not want to play on my phone I I didn't want to play on my
play it yeah I didn't want to play on my phone because like
I said I I don't do very well at rhythm games so it was like
I felt like like i had to play on a bigger screen too like
when i play rhythm games so i was just like you know what i
do need to do stuff too i i do have to do stuff um uh i even
got an apple pencil so i was like i do need it so it was
like i was typing too when i was playing it was fun i really
enjoyed it um so i'm glad i made the investment because i
actually i actually did need a new i i didn't have i don't
have an ipad so i did need it so it was just very convenient
all right what show okay we still have uh the showcase um
and uh but i got bought i had to i bought an apple pencil
because i had to write some stuff that i need to send to
people so uh so uh i did have to do that
pick one showcase that we're i know everything i know there
was like a nintendo direct at like okay we watch showcases
showcase which one do you guys want we're not i i will say
the one night that i won't be doing will the summer game
fest only because it's two hours long it's like two to three
hours long so we have a choice of either the sony xbox or
nintendo direct because the the summer game fest is two
hours long and I have I had two hours of sleep today because
I have really bad jet lag um and then so I have really bad
jet lag so I had only two hours of sleep I chugged down uh
coffee and then and then caught I was just like I'm ready oh
yeah where's my phone where is it I want to see the video I
was sent it's like so random too alright xbox I see more I
should do a pull I can't believe I'm not doing a pull then
let me do a pull real quick uh I'm ready for some do
apparently I saw someone uh I saw Twitter someone mentioned
that uh someone on Twitter someone mentioned that majority
one of the showcases was dokey slop
uh xbox it's so neat it's like friend slot but it's jokie
slot because it's all gear games gear towards me uh summer
game fest on 1.5x speed uh nintendo direct i could wait i
could allow additional votes or i want actually i just want
to cause a war so i'll put that you can pay to win for your
showcase you're finally spending you can finally spend your
stuff now
pay to win now you can pay to win you're spending one point
to pay him to pay to win
Finally, there's special events, right?
All right, here we go.
This is your time to shine.
People are spending fast.
Fight for your showcase.
Okay, while we do that, I have to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
I have not used to...
I had so much coffee, and I did not use the bathroom for
four hours.
I'll be right back.
Award going on.
Sorry, I had to get more water, too.
Sony is catching up.
God, hold the line.
Wait, I...
Wait, I was...
I was looking at Twitter.
I had Twitter open while you guys were having your war.
Wait, do we also got sponsored?
We all... but we're both just gaming?
I still finished last.
I'm pretty sure I started first.
started first and i finished last yeah was that the longest
that was
i like how people are still voting for nintendo direct as if
like uh as if like their points matt still matter no it's
milk patting with twitch private thank you no yeah exact you
guys should have got a clicker like those uh auto clickers
yeah my live ass has lost five years i still have hope i was
gonna say we were still voting intended to direct us if they
had a chance that's if they were gonna get there yeah i did
my part sent 981 points nintendo bros still had hope right
there all right i'm gonna download the video i did not set
up okay uh what was it let's see how long it takes xbox do i
have let's see how much space i have i need gigabytes is i'm
gonna download it um i have enough as long as the video is
not 17.3 gigabytes or five
can't be that bad uh how long is this showcase let's see
we're gonna download the video and see how how far this can
take us 4k 60 fp yeah no wait was it part of the summer okay
wait oh it's part of this part of this summer game fest i
didn't even realize yeah let's see how fast my internet is
all right let's see we'll do it live how much last time it
was worth it we get what we wanted all right you know what
2.69 gigabytes can't be that bad all right let's see how far
okay five two minutes oh my god wait wait a minute shout out
to fiber shout out to my boy fiber i had two devices
spamming points
nice two minutes for Oh, never mind.
It's now at three minutes.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, now back to two minutes.
The tell who spent the most points.
It does not.
Oh, maybe it did, but I, like, looked away.
Alright, so I'm already, I'm running at one gigabyte left.
Yeah, I already downloaded one gigabyte, guys.
Oh, who was it?
Someone spent 900.
Wait.
Who was, I, 900, it was a dude.
spent yeah i did my part for my phone oh my god this guy
clicked 981 times in five minutes yeah dude got 981 the
thing is i set the poll timer to five minutes that guy was
clicking more than one second per click yeah that's crazy so
would do the math guys do the math bro that guy's 8 p.m goes
hard that's three clicks per second that dude was gaming And
he did it all on the phone, guys.
He had a whole click farm.
Yeah, he was farm-clicking.
Oh, that's funny.
That's funny that, like, a bunch of us were streaming at the
same time.
That's funny.
All right.
We're almost there.
39 seconds left.
All right, let me see.
How long did they stream for?
I hope I did well.
I'm my sponsor.
I hope everyone had fun watching.
I had fun playing.
It was more so for me.
Oh, wait.
Do we win one hour overtime too?
It wasn't just me.
is so cute that's cute wait oh my god it's like she's
actually playing that is so cute
i love that that's so like immersive it's like she's showing
her ipad oh my god wait it's like she's showing her hands
too wait she's really good it's like i look at this and then
i look at my own gameplay i was like that's not is she on
hard too what was she on oh that does not look like hard
difficulty guys
that that did not look like hard difficulty
that is cool though all right all right what else what okay
oh matara was also played also i finished downloading the
showcase but matara was also playing it was it on I'm glad
that she fixed her internet issue.
I saw that she was having issues with it.
Oh my god, wait, no.
Oh my god, no, she went further than me.
Oh my god.
She went more overtime than me.
Wait, how did they do...
Oh, it's because they're on their phone.
I wasn't on my phone.
I wasn't on a phone.
Wait, what about?
Yeah, I'm scoping.
I'm scoping the other sponsors.
I'm trying to see if I could, you know, get Intel.
I wanted to, like, grab Intel, you know.
It's not the same size as mine.
That has to be.
This is Res.
I'm stocking real quick.
I'm sponsored portion.
I'm stalking.
Wait, what's it like?
Oh my god.
Wait, I just noticed.
Okay.
I didn't realize, guys, I didn't realize that when I was
game capturing it, a little.
I didn't realize it was not lagging on my iPad.
On the OBS screen, on the OBS screen, it did not look that
slow.
Ew.
Yeah, it, I, I, it did not, that's why you guys were like,
please increase the speed.
I swear to God, I did not notice it.
It was the screen.
Yeah, I did not know.
Okay, you guys didn't know this, too.
That's good.
Sorry.
It was not lagging.
Yeah.
Guys, never mind.
JK, it was not lagging.
It was, it's not.
JK.
It ran, the capture ran perfectly.
I wonder if it's because I was playing way too long.
Let me double check.
Maybe because I, it could be.
I'm going to double check.
all right guys yeah it was not it was not lagging
guys it was not lagging guys it was okay guys we were fine
all right anyway anyway let's do the showcase so it was fine
thing it's okay i'm glad that i'm glad no one else every
everybody else also thought it looked very similar yeah um
let's see yeah because like all my obs it like did not look
like it would look it looked like i don't know if it was
like from the string no because i was like myself my skin
suit wasn't lagging it but it was like the game capture but
i don't know it was because of the uh the screen or anything
it could be honestly all right let's uh but at least we had
fun at least we had fun jamming out you know we had fun
jamming out together it was all about the jamming out
portion so
the thing oh wait i noticed it when i had 10 speed on when i
had 10 It does not look like it.
It was just when I was on default.
When it was default for me, it was like...
It felt fast.
Yeah, there's some parts where it's five.
Bana, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
Sorry, I'm rewashing me being an absolute gamer.
Uh-
You know...
I gotta appreciate it.
I was watching myself be a fucking gamer right there.
Okay, now, okay, let me...
On like, um, on hard difficulty.
Okay, now, now we react.
Okay, sorry.
I got a little distracted.
This download was done like five, like, maybe like 10
minutes ago.
I got a little distracted there.
Whoops.
It was this.
All right, let's see.
If it's loud, I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
It's just the showcase, right?
Thank you for what?
Okay.
All right.
Hope it is.
Let me know, sound guy.
Oh, yeah.
Let me change the title really quick.
Before we...
I'm just going to download the rest of the other showcases
too.
for next time.
Maybe I'll do it on my rest day because it's just like a
chill day.
So watching the Xbox Gaming Showcase.
Yeah, but I won't be specific.
All right, here you go.
I tried not to get spoiled too much about it.
I saw like little bits of like some of the stuff that was
like on Twitter because you know people were freaking out
about it.
But like I tried not to get spoiled for it because there's
so many showcases.
I'll spoil a little bit for the direct as well.
Just a little bit.
Because they released everything!
I was not gonna...
I was not...
I'm sorry.
I know I was still awake, but I knew today was gonna be a
very long day.
That is a lot of warnings.
That's...
a lot of warnings let me know if i have to tone tune down
the turn down the volume or anything there are reports of
multiple tremors causing minor damage across kolona stay
sharp don't let them surround you what is this wait is this
the gears of what is this here strap these on this isn't
enough
I think he sounds like John DiMaggio.
In the thick-ass necks.
Yeah, I was like, that's John DiMaggio right there.
The hats of you.
I know that.
I know that Jake, the dogs scream anywhere.
Oh, it's four players, too.
You can get the whole crew.
Oh, it's the prequel.
voice actor, but they have to, like, be younger.
Or better, yeah.
I think it's always funny.
Or, like, because, you know, like, you know, they obviously
do not sound younger.
They obviously don't sound younger than, like, ooh, they're
playing.
Like, you know.
Because voice is aged.
Yeah, I used to...
I used to smoke so much, but I got better.
Yeah, because you can tell John DiMaggio sounds a lot older.
He sounds a lot older than he should be.
Okay, Sound Guy said to bring it up slightly more.
I brought it up slightly, Sound Guy.
Let me know.
It looks really fun.
It does.
I like that it's gameplay footage and not renders.
I...
Uh, but a sound guy.
I did update a bit more, so let me know if you want me to
update more.
I think that's my favorite part.
Oh, I thought he was shooting his teammates, because that
would be me.
Yeah, I don't care.
Yeah, it could be...
You know, you know, it's like Blizzard with the cinematics
and stuff.
Like, that's fine.
But, like, I'm just tired of being disappointed.
You know?
Like, I guess if it's, like, Blizzard doing, like,
cinematics, that's fine.
Like, there's some...
I feel like Blizzard would be a really great, like,
animation company.
Like, that's fine.
I don't mind that.
But, like, a lot of other game companies don't really know
how to do cinematics.
Like, do, like, pre-renders stuff really well.
We know what Diablo looks like.
Like, the cinematics do not look like...
Like, it was cinematics.
It's fine.
But if it's, like, pre-renders shit, fuck that.
But we need to make ourselves skids I do like that gameplay
So I know like what we're getting
Oh that's hardcore Where's the gears Of war
Oh Oh wait that's just the
The graphics looks amazing.
I can't wait to not be able to render this.
I can't wait to put all my graphics in though when I'm
playing on stream.
At least I get to see what it looks like if I could.
That's so true.
I can't wait to see Doki as a powerpoint.
Oh, the blood spatter on the screen?
Oh, shit.
I can't wait to see you play it because it doesn't run on my
PC.
I'd be surprised if we could run GTA, the new GTA game,
honestly, for all of us.
by the time a new GTA comes out we're gonna have a new new
we're gonna have a 70x series graphics card they're gonna be
like you to play this game you must wait another two years
for the 70x graphics card
oh yeah the disc space you have to buy entirely new console
oh wait that's what the PlayStation 6 is gonna V4.
The entire PlayStation 6 will fit one new GTA.
If you want to play any other game, you need an external
hard drive.
Oh yeah, before he dies.
Oh yeah, I saw that.
I saw like the other GTAs are back too.
The remasters.
E-Day.
Oh, I like how it's E-Day.
That's, that's funny.
This bad boy can fit an entire GTA in it.
Welcome to the Xbox Game Showcase.
For the past 25 years, Xbox has delivered some of the
greatest games of all time.
Games that changed what was possible.
Games that brought players together in games that defined
generations.
Look under your seat.
see if i knew she was going to give away free xboxes i'd be
there too i fly back from korea just to go here so yeah
apparently that gears of war eda will be an xbox console
exclusive apparently uh uh everyone that went there uh got a
free xbox great games and that's what today is all about and
it's like exclusive to this 25 titles to this con uh to the
showcase by our gears direct Enjoy the show.
There's a whole thing was apparently the CEO is trying to
bring back bring back like exclusives and stuff.
So they even brought exclusive Xbox.
I don't know if you could buy it.
Can you buy it?
I don't know if anyone can get it outside of the showcase.
No?
Yeah.
I remember her fingers gripped so tightly in mind that her
nails drew blood.
In November?
You mean the scalpers will get it in November?
I lost her grip.
Finally, the good old days, the console wars.
We're bringing it back.
We're nostalgia baiting everything.
Guys.
You guys missed the console wars?
We're bringing it back.
that fact too you thought the nostalgia fate is gonna end
with just shows bring back wars
console world world war two
the good old days
that's what i was missing out on the library oh goody oh Now
in 4K!
What if it was hard?
Sorry to interrupt.
We run it back.
Oh yeah, and I play graphics on low.
4K library and I'm running on like...
And what?
No, because I'll be on a PlayStation for it.
Guys, I will be on a PlayStation.
My advice.
Yeah, they apparently have two, they have, they added new,
oh wait, oh wait, I should have, let me pause this.
It's not a professional streamer.
I should tweet out, I'm doing a showcase now for those who
have been waiting for it, and I was still streaming, uh,
colorful sage.
We are doing it.
We are watching the Xbox Showcase.
it's you know for those that were like hey it's five she
should be watching it now right and i was still playing miku
miku oh we you another mika i might have went over time i
might have went over time with miku uh and miku but So I'm
doing one watch a night.
And then the rest on Thursday.
No rest days.
Let's go.
Very smart decision from Doki Bird.
There we go.
Uh-oh.
Rest day God.
So I have collab.
Yeah, sure this won't backfire anything.
Let's go.
Should say the Xbox showcase.
Now.
There you go.
I had a one letter.
Let's go.
I would like to play the new one.
I just need to find someone with a PS5 to play this way.
John Haley he talks in the later games which one's this
there's something on this island it's like it calls to me
you and my father found that island thanks to me there's
more to this than you understand he talks a lot now yeah
that's what I'm saying oh wait I forgot he talks I already
talked in the first game or not.
I knew we talked too much in the live action.
That never existed.
Oh, is it Plagetown?
Isn't that a multiplayer?
Wasn't that a multiplayer?
No, I was thinking about something else.
Yeah.
Look at this place.
It's mad.
I was thinking, oh, I was thinking about this other game.
I was thinking about I was thinking about, you know, like
the two brothers.
with the rats.
I was thinking about that one.
They're all dead.
Move.
Lenny.
You know those ancient death curse rumors?
Well, maybe they're true.
Sit in.
Oh, it is.
Oh, it is that one.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I was thinking about the brothers
with the rats.
That's why you're like playing down.
I'm like, yeah.
Where's...
Does she not have sisters?
Like...
You ever heard?
Oh, I saw...
I got spoiled for this one.
Who wouldn't get...
Okay, to be fair, like...
Like, no one shut up about this one.
Oh, it's a brother's sister.
Oh, yeah, okay.
I thought it was two...
I thought it was two brothers.
How?
Where are we?
Oh.
Feels like we're someplace totally different.
How many times has this one...
been remasters though wasn't this uh this was originally uh
was it only one other time this is the third time yeah
because i i remember uh i remember playing trying to play
this psp yes i had the psp version of this yeah good times
never seem to last long do they i hate you sneaky Or was it
PS?
I don't remember.
I remember because of that detective.
There's a lot of pictures of that one.
That's why I remembered this game.
I know that the detective was very popular.
Oh, I think I had it on the PlayStation 2.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, PlayStation 2, not PSV.
I played a little bit of this.
This one and also the one with the gun.
Persona.
Yeah, four and five.
I know about it.
Three.
Sorry.
Three and four.
The gun one and that one.
What's this?
Yeah.
I just know.
I played three and four.
I played like, I don't know.
Like one to two.
I made, you know, I think playing two days of Persona for
each game is like pretty far for me.
You know?
I think it's an accomplishment for me.
general no it's a zombie could be dying way or something
it's a zombie game yeah you know i think i got pretty far
with playing like at least two days of a persona sad decay i
know some of you guys already know what it is you're like
you watch this showcase already and you're like oh i think
it might be state of decay
All right, who is role-playing right now?
No way.
No way in them.
You're like, oh my God, I can't believe I guessed it right.
Not, I don't know.
Just very committed to the role-play.
It's like we're watching it live, guys.
It just came out.
We're literally watching it live right now.
All right, who's laughing right now?
Pushed back against the night.
It got alarm as if it is live.
It's not my version, Toki.
Toki has my version.
We have to pretending that this was last week.
This is like a recording of last week's stream.
Don't ruin the role play.
Yeah, I'm actually watching this blind.
I'm so committed to the role blade.
I'm actually living through it.
Oh, I saw this funny tweet where it was like...
I was going to quote retweet it when I was in Korea.
But I was like, oh, fuck it.
It was like...
Without Silk Song, there's no punchline.
And it was like the Joker gif.
And I was going to say...
I was going to quote retweet it and write Bloodborne.
Because I would be like...
What can we joke about now?
That Silk Song's release.
We still have Bloodborne, guys.
We still...
We still have Bloodborne.
Or Titanfall.
Titanfall 3.
Alright, State...
I've never played State of Decay.
No way, it's State of Decay?
I'm down in...
try it out see of these there have been plenty of grand
adventures but you're still updating your own sea of thieves
experience with our new free update custom seas you can let
me explain i've always wanted to play see if these ways to
play like robot royale we're small but bloodthirsty i've
never played cfe's we never got proof for it when i was
still in court though
Microsoft firms because why would Microsoft reply to emails
about permissions, you know?
Or maybe you just want to spawn this.
Like, they'll be like, just play the game.
And absolutely loads of these.
We had zero Microsoft firms either like, just play the game,
you know?
Why are you asking permission?
You can show romance.
Or maybe just show the world from a whole new perspective.
Or you could even just create a place to hide.
Literally, if you want.
It's like Western companies normally, it's really hard to
get perused because in their heads, they're just like, yes,
play the game.
You know?
Because they're like, play it.
Like every streamer is playing it.
Like, why do you need to ask me permission?
Just boot up Twitch and you'll see every streamer playing
that game right now.
The tools are now in your hands.
What you do with them is up to you.
Oh, there's King of the Hill.
That's cool.
Just try not to wreck the place.
There's Team Deathmatch.
We're just, I'm so going to lose.
I have never played CFE's.
I feel like I'm going to absolutely destroy it.
I heard Destiny 2's newest patch came out today.
The last patch.
Sorry, the newest and last patch.
I didn't realize it was today.
I would have streamed it.
i just have too many stuff going on today the final one yeah
they call him when does destiny 2 fully end your name is
this metro is hunter there's
a spartan wait you were a legend yeah the server shut down
you stood for something Oh, I thought the sir it was shut
the I never finished Metro.
I know I'd be started Metro a while ago, but then I was like
From you There's just too many stuff to play you promised
the brighter future There's no worse.
Oh, I There was just so many things today.
I wish maybe I'll try out your name I'm sad.
I wish I could have there was just too many things to stream
It was just like too many things to stream.
And I would have loved to experience the Destiny 2 patch
with everybody.
I was just so...
Yeah.
It was fun to be there with everybody.
Okay.
Dragonborns and I will be there together.
The worst part is not to rebuy.
Ah!
I'm not buying all of it.
I'll revive what I mean for the new patch
I don't yet think oh that's great.
It's 20% off.
Thank God one last ride One last ride That legendary Spartan
is gone
Yes, because I did lose the company account only because it
was under the company email.
So like I had zero access to it because it'll be like send
the password.
Because you know, the moment you leave, you don't have
access to anymore unless you change the email in time.
Unless you change the email in time.
And obviously I didn't change the email in time.
So, like, you know, when you're logging in, you can't log in
because they're like, oh, it's a new location.
Please check your email to, you know, to put in the code.
I couldn't check the email.
Yeah.
Oh, there's Kroki.
Oh my god, this is Doki Kor.
This is Doki Slop right there.
Wait, we have to play this.
play this this is this is croaky slab
burning a forest equals toky it's literally me peak croaky
slab
why can't oh wait she doesn't have wings oh that's so sad
she's paraplegic bad
pot coming 2027 there day one with game pass world premiere
this is exclusive which one was i guess a lot of some of
these games are exclusive
she's not bad um that's ibis for calling her bad It's
because she can only, she only has one wing.
What's this?
She ninja.
Wait.
Is this...
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say, go away.
Is this a dinosaur?
Is this a warriors game?
It's world premiere.
Oh, Wolong?
Awaken.
Phoenix.
Oh, I saw that.
All the games are trying to avoid November.
Oh, Wolong 2.
I don't think I played Wolong 1.
Uh, I saw that on Twitter.
People were like, all the game releases are not on...
So...
Uh...
Are not on November.
There's Barbie.
What the fuck?
There's a Barbie game?
Um, spoilers.
Guess who would say Barbie on November?
Oh, I'm here.
Guys, I'm playing a real game on November.
Oh, this is a cult.
Is it about cults?
What the fuck is this?
Everybody playing GTA and I'll be playing Barbie.
Teaming with locals.
waiting to join our family i just looks like a integrated
twitch game or like your twitch viewers can be part of your
cult like uh what's it called the cult of the lab oh there's
four player co-op oh yeah this is a friend slot but this
it's like long-term friend slot though you can't play one
you can't it's not one uh No, I don't think this could be a
stoppy sisters just because like this is a long-term game
and I do not think All four of us can get together To do a
long series on this
World premiere Is every co-op guess language is a funny
thing Yeah scheduling would be a nightmare
Oh, you know what, guys?
On November, I'm playing Barbie.
On the day...
I'll spoil it.
I'll spoil my schedule.
The day the new GTA releases, I'm going to be streaming
Barbie.
Because the thing is, everyone will be playing GTA.
But I'll be playing Barbie.
You know?
I play against the grain.
And it makes...
When everyone is special, no one is special.
Okay, well two viewers are 200k.
Yeah, boys play GTA 6.
Men play Barbie.
It's like Barbie Heimer all over again.
Yeah, but you could put my stream on the side while you play
GTA 6.
Because I won't be spoiling anything.
What game is this?
There's so many cults.
Is cults a new space?
I'm starting to think it's a little bit.
It's room two.
I'm going to take trash out.
It's turning into a silly turning to a gamer because I'm
busy I've been.
It's a new one.
Ah, this drink sucks.
I bought like a...
melted, oh well.
Um, I had another drink that I bought outside of the coffee
to drink later, but all of them always melted, so now it's,
like, too watered down.
Hmm.
Is this the online?
A sprawling paradise.
Meet the locals learn to fish.
Doesn't that sound nice?
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's the fall of 76.
This is no time to hoard.
Share your stroke of luck with your power.
All aboard build your camp as a team.
I'm gonna get a new plot key But in this Appalachian
wonderland all God suits it's worse than expected Enemies
are waiting in places undetected so suit up son and defend
our great nation and gather all your friends when you fight
this Infestation that's the play daddy.
Oh, we'll tackle them all rebuilding our bright future from
the ashes rising Right after Elder Scrolls.
That's funny.
We're gonna get Skyrim PlayStation 6 remaster before then.
We're getting that one first.
Right after Skyrim gets remastered on the PlayStation 6,
then we might get the new Elder Scrolls.
Our vlog has been led astray by your acts of defiance.
Argentinore troubles in the wake of your actions.
They follow you now.
Why is this Doom?
Oh, this is Doom.
Why is that portal?
Or new.
New Doom report.
Or Doom DLC.
See, I've never played any of the Doom games.
So, I've played a lot of Doom adjacent games.
I've never played any of them.
I know they're really good.
I've played a lot of adjacent Doom games.
Like the Boomer Shoes.
genres it's like try try to do a glance against the fucking
gun like bro you're not killing him this guy has been to
hell like how many times and he still comes back you're not
like
we're there yeah so like i always see it you know like the
the demo stations i always see the demo stations i see like
all the boys playing it on a demo station and it always
looks so fun but like my dad was a sony boy so which is
funny that we're watching the xbox showcase right now um
shout out to the guy who clicked three clicks per second
pit points well spent
oh asian empires on the xbox this is an rts I don't know.
An RTS game on console has always been pretty hard to play.
APM doesn't really...
Yeah, I know there's Halo Wars, but like...
Still.
It's still like weird to play.
As an RTS player, I do perform...
for playing it on PC versus on consoles.
I do like mouse and keyboard more.
Pikmin exists and it, guys, remember how many Pikmin died
when I played Pikmin?
Guys, you remember how many Pikmin lives we lost during the
last level.
Remember the final boss?
When we try to play, when we We did the final boss and then
they all got they all got squashed
I still remember that and the and and to be fair and those
pigmen during the final level I didn't kill them
intentionally that time
This is minecraft dungeons.
I know like minecraft dungeons is really popular in arcades
Yeah They have like a pay to win Minecraft Dungeons and
arcades where you have to scan like, oh hey, that's the
warden where you can get like little trading cards and then
you can scan it and stuff.
And it's like pay to win.
I played it once.
And then like it was, you know, it's like an arcade game.
So it obviously like is very skewed into spending as many
coins as possible.
But I know, like, the kids love it.
I know Minecraft Dungeon is, like, super popular.
Yeah, the OG.
I spent so much money on the Jurassic Park one, and then the
Time Stop, and the Simpsons one.
And what should I...
This is why I spent so many coins on.
Admirers of the mysteries of magic.
Take your seats before the lights go down and the curtain
rises.
For our next act is about to begin.
And then Marlowe versus Capcom.
Are you sitting comfortably?
Final performance.
To witness feats both mystifying and illuminating.
Watch closely then and let the shadows tell the devil's
deal.
I don't know my nose.
The famous Jacob Manjuro.
Okay, I need to eat dinner.
I do I need to eat food.
I'm sorry.
I'm like because of jet lag.
I'm lost track of like because I ate like I couldn't sleep.
So I ate at like five in the morning.
And I was like, do I?
I used to try.
I remember when I last ate.
Do a deal with the devil.
The master sought yet more power.
Like check.
I'm checking my stats.
And in the darkness.
I had to like check my stat, my hunger bar real quick.
But the devil had other plans.
He pulled Jacob from his own nightmare.
I was like, give me a sec.
Let me check my hunger meter.
legions their tricks every abomination what is my stamina
bar take what should have been his is this
i'm playing with my hud right now i'm a real gamer what is
this oh demons
oh a demon that's your cue oh it's like how magic is he run
you know how How, like, uh...
What?
What the fuck?
Oh, because magic is evil, get it?
Okay, you know what this trailer reminds me of?
It reminds me of, uh...
It's another British game.
I like how... Oh, oh, that's cool.
But, like, I hope it's cool.
I like that.
I like the war building here.
This is interesting.
Okay, you know what this?
I'm gonna pause this.
I'm gonna pause this because I control I control the Xbox
Live showcase, guys, which is all live.
Don't worry, me and the CEO, we're tight like that.
Whoa, that's why I paused the showcase for everybody.
How do you do that live?
Anyway, you know what this reminds me of?
I don't know if he has, it's, uh, everyone hold up.
I have a, I have a commentary to do.
I, um, it reminds me of that game where it was like the
happy pills from the, the, it's like also a British game,
but then that game, we happy few.
The whole aesthetic, the whole aesthetic of this game
reminds me of We Happy Feud, but that game is ass.
Yeah, it was such a good idea, but the game itself was
really bad.
I didn't play, I just watched people play it, and then I was
just like, I was so interested in it, and I saw the reviews,
and I saw people's gameplay, and this reminds me of We Happy
Feud, set in the UK but like the aesthetic of everything and
like how the stop the game the style too because I really
like the story and the aesthetic of we happy few and this
reminds me of it yeah the style and the aesthetic the deal's
a deal Jacob I'll see you soon
oh is it actually the developers wait did I got it right
it's developed by the we happy few developers That game?
Is that true?
No way.
That's crazy if it is.
You're alive?
Are you one guying me?
Oh, it's not.
That was a one guy.
Yeah, we got one guy.
That's gonna be like, shit.
He won God.
I think it was his first message, too.
Just to...
Oh, wait.
No, it was a Raider message.
not.
Oh, is this?
What is this?
No.
To destroy your enemies, break their will.
What game?
Is this Napoleon?
I was just saying Napoleon Dynamite.
Is this?
What is this?
Oh, is this?
Oh, is it like Dark Souls, but what if we're in France?
Oh, it is.
But it's like living in France is right now.
I'm sorry.
But Like, that's just real life.
That's just real life.
Napoleon souls.
It's French souls.
Just like real life.
For your empire.
This is how the French.
No, they'll be on strike before we get into any fight.
It's no, I don't know if it's like that right now, but like,
I remember like 10 years ago.
Oh, it is Napoleon.
I was like, it's not, I was gonna say, is that Napoleon
dynamite?
Like, it's Napoleon.
Valor Mortis.
Ah, yes.
Just like how I remembered in the history books.
But like, uh, parrot, like, a lot of people get culture
shock when they visit Paris because it's not.
like how they imagine in the movies and the books because
it's like very romanticized but it's very dirty back i don't
know if it still is but 10 years ago it's like very dirty
and like uh lots of rats and a lot of really smelly um
because like a lot of like workers in paris go on strike
very often um are you ready to talk about yeah so they're
always going on strike which is very common in france in
general.
So because of that, a lot of like the members will show you
the yeah, just classic friends things you know.
And then sometimes you don't even get public transport on
the day you're there because they'll be on strike.
The bus drivers will be on strike.
Yes, strikes and so it's like you know, yeah, wait to take
the bus today.
If that's not cut your style step out of the shadows and
take a direct approach.
There's other treasure all around the world.
If you know where to look and are willing to fight for it.
Oh is this Elder Scrolls online?
Whether it's fortune, adventure, or danger.
You just need the app to check if there's striking.
Oh, ESO.
What's wrong with Elder Scrolls online?
Is it because they're now making Elder Scrolls 6?
Yeah!
They're just like...
Elder Scrolls online.
Just because they're not.
They don't... We just want Elder Scrolls 6.
It's your national parks and national monuments.
This is a walking sim.
Oh.
It's the playing game.
It's the flight sim.
Is it the flight sim?
We'll bring it back.
Because it went so well the first time I played it.
I can't wait to see that mountain.
Very, very close.
Guys.
Especially the Grand Canyon.
I can't wait to see that mountain.
be very safe there.
Now you can crash with the natural wonders.
I've always wanted to crash into the Grand Canyon and live.
Wait, can I crash into the bison?
I've always wondered what it was like to go dead first into
that bison.
I wonder if it reacts to it or if it cuts the black the
moment you go in.
Now with more options.
That's why I've always won it, guys.
Oh, shit.
Wait, is this competitive flight sim?
Bro, how the fuck am I going to compete against that?
They're going to have...
What?
They're going to have, like, the entire setup.
You know, like, those driving setups with the actual, like,
wheels and the seat and everything.
They're going to have their...
And they're going to have, like, the whole, like, cockpit of
the plane.
The 40k.
setup how am i gonna be top 500 i'm gonna hack i'm gonna aim
bot i'm gonna play bot i guess that's where it wins me of
mechanisms as the old order begins to fall you know what's
crazy i'm about to tell you like the one thing i knew i got
i got spoiled on There was no Smash Bros.
announcement.
Everyone was like, this is it!
Everyone was disappointed yet...
Impressed with the Nintendo Direct from what I've heard.
Everyone was like, it has to be...
It has to be Smash Bros.
It has to be.
There were two audiences for the Nintendo Direct.
Guys, guys, no spoilers.
Guys, no spoilers.
We gotta pretend as if we're watching this live.
But I'm not pretending.
I am watching this live.
I just know there was no...
I know there was no Smash Bros.
Because people were really angry.
But we're not pretending.
Because this is live.
Oh, Castlevania.
I have come here to destroy you.
Just like my father.
I remember her.
She was in the anime on Netflix.
I saw her in the anime.
Oh, she looks like Kami.
Oh, she's new?
She looks like Kami and the Magic Girl had a kid.
Yuri, am I right?
You must use it wisely.
Yeah.
Better control your curse and strengthen yourself.
Kinda.
You are no more than a irritating thing.
What makes you think you can...
I've never played a Castlevania game either.
Castlevania is like Metroid, right?
It's Metroid, Metroidvane.
Like, it's a Metroid-style game, right?
Metroidvania?
Like...
Yeah, I've never played a Metrovania type game before.
Have I?
No, I don't think so.
I never grew up with it.
And I will hunt the night.
Wait, it's Hollow Knight Metrovania?
Oh.
I saw it as like a platformer.
Platform souls.
I didn't realize.
All right.
Hollow Knight was my very first Metrovania game.
That's a Platform Souls-like game.
Like...
They call it Platform Souls.
Some years have a color to them.
A haze that seems to fill the whole world.
What's this?
Oh, the art sounds so pretty!
Reminds me of Studio Ghibli.
And it's glow.
That's cute.
You discover wonderful new places.
Dear friends, you always needed.
This feels so AI.
It's because AI girls like to use Ghibli styles on stuff
now.
But this is just heavily inspired by Ghibli.
It's a yellow filter.
You know why it feels like AI?
But look, she has five fingers, so you know this is an AI.
Yeah.
Streams.
This, I don't know if it is for it.
It looks very just, it looks slice of life.
Yeah, Bavarian.
It's cute.
It reminds me of that Shin-chan game that I've always wanted
to play.
But I know, like, it's only popular in Japan.
Like, Shin-chan is such a popular...
You can tell, like, what games are popular in NA and what's
games popular in Japan.
But that's what it reminds me of.
Oh.
Another Atlas game.
yeah it it's uh there's a lot of a lot of good games i heard
like x this was like xbox their best showcase in a long time
what's this
oh spooky
very spooky vibes pieces Oh, Persona.
I'm not a fan of the logo.
Guys, okay.
The logo.
That's my GTA 6.
The logo reminds me of, like, Green Lantern.
Yeah, DC.
Yeah, it looks like Green Lantern slash DC logo.
Yeah.
I hope that's not the final logo.
Oh, I saw this.
Oh, my God.
I saw this.
Okay, I got so out of this.
I was so happy about this.
It's spider.
I'm sorry.
I'm joking my mission.
But I was so happy about this.
I am a little scared, though, because I don't really like
how the gameplay looks because it reminds me of Spiral 4.
The, what was it called?
The...
It reminds me of Spiral 4.
for which I was not a huge fan of like the post original
trilogy you know the first the game after the original
trilogy was so bad and this the gameplay really looked like
that like I
remember like it just gave me that feeling so I hope it is I
hope it I I hope it isn't like that because like uh what's
the company uh the company's like toys for bobs for toys or
whatever they've never like they never made their own spiral
game before because it was a remake it was a remake of from
insomniac so i'm worried because like you know they were
bullets are flying i'm really i'm really worried because I
love Spyro.
It's one of my favorite franchises, like the original
trilogy.
Oh, Toys to Life, sorry.
And I'm really worried, oh, this guy's dead.
But, like, they did do an original Crash, but they'd never
done an original Spyro game yet.
Because the remake of Spyro was, you know, it was Insaniac
that remade Spyro.
And, but, like, Toys for Life never made their own original
Spyro game.
yet before and i think spiral games are harder to make than
crash bandicoot games because crash bandicoot games it's
like streamlined you know it's like um crash bandicoot game
is like you know platformer and um it's there's one
direction to go but spiral game is like slightly more
because there's a lot of missions everywhere and stuff like
that and it had a different you know it's a different world
like level design and everything compared to crash a bit
more open yeah it's very And Insomnia perfected...
I'm sorry, I'm a huge Spyro friend.
Insomnia perfected the formula for Spyro.
And every sequel after that...
I'm so sorry.
I know a lot of people love the Cinder ones.
I played it.
It's like a different genre.
The ones with Spyro's girlfriend.
It's like a different genre to the original trilogy.
Some people love it only because they love Cinder.
and also furries uh and elijah went too i guess it's true
but like i it was okay it was okay i didn't like that game
that much honestly um i'm i wasn't a huge fan of the cinder
games i think it was hard carried by the fact that like um
people were like oh my god cinders like oh my god I think it
was like literally hard carried by the character cinder Um,
but I legitimately I wasn't like I bought I bought all the
spiral games not skylander I'm sorry he could he was too
ugly.
I'm sorry.
I'm not strong enough like Tokyo only like spy for yes Yes,
I want if I I would like my dragon to have to be an eye
candy.
Okay, like I can't I'm sorry I never played skylander.
I never own any Skylander games and they made Spyro really
fucking ugly and I was like I'm not, I don't want to look at
this guy I don't want to like, I don't I was like, I want my
I want my Spyro to at least be aesthetically pleasing to
look at like so I never, I played every Spyro game except
for Skylanders yeah so even the shitty ones I did not finish
the shitty ones which one was it Spyro oh my god I'm trying
to remember oh god you were so bad I'm like I'm like
remembering like not Realm Beyond I actually want Spyro
franchise game oh yeah also the Elijah Woods one was when
they made and then they kept making sparks buffer and buffer
it was so weird it was people were concerned because nobody
saw sparks in there um during like that one tiny segment of
the gameplay trailer which is a little concerning i will it
is definitely a little concerning that uh you couldn't see
you couldn't see him uh i yeah i will agree to that um let's
see i'm trying to okay the legend of spire i played a legend
the legend of spiral was oh god they were all so bad okay i
mean obviously there's a big fan base for the Legend of
Spyro, but oh my god.
I played all of the Legend of Spyro.
I never finished Legend of Spyro.
I think it was Ender of Dragonfly.
Oh, this is terrible.
Absolutely terrible.
And, uh, was it, yeah, was Ender of the Dragonfly?
Oh, what's this one?
No, it was Ender of the Dragonfly.
It was, God, which one was it?
Was Ender of the Dragonfly?
Let me look at this.
It was...
it was not entered a dragonfly it was something else it was
it i'm trying to find it there was one that was so bad i'm
trying to find it um yeah oh was it it was okay it was
entered a dragonfly okay i was gonna say it was entered a
dragonfly and a hero's tale oh my god okay for those who
don't know they try to make an rpg spiral game and it was
called a hero's tale and then um what's I did not like how
they butchered hunter He was so weird.
I don't know what to say I don't know what to say but like
there was so much dialogue I think that was like the worst
part It was like they were trying to do a lord building and
stuff They tried to do like lord building with a hunt like
with a hero's tale It was so much talking like It was like,
like, it was like Lord Dump, Lord Dump.
Every time you talk to someone, it was just like, uh,
exposition dump every time.
And then the text looks so ugly.
I'm sorry.
I know there's like a random thing to gripe about, but like,
it was so, it was just the text for the dialogue was so
ugly.
So it like, I was not immersed at all.
And then in the Legend of...
And then for those who don't know, the Legend of...
What was it?
What's it called?
The new series.
The Legend of Spyro.
They rebooted Spyro.
So everything we learned about Spyro is gone.
Yeah, it was like Lord of the Rings exposition for the
hero's tale.
That's the hero's tale.
And in Legend of Spyro, they rebooted the entire game.
The entire lore was rewritten.
And then, um, and then, uh, and so, like, Spyro was adopted
by Sparks' parents.
You know, I know, they're dragonflies.
I know.
Oh, God.
So Spyro is considered, like, the rarest purple dragon, and
only one is born after, like, X amount of years.
Like, after millennia, only one purple dragon is born.
So he was, like, the special dragon.
And then, apparently, he was so special that, like, the evil
wizard had to kill him.
him uh because he was like prophesied to like he was
prophesied to like kill the evil wizard so then they're like
we have to and then so so the dragons sent spiral out into
the world um to like protect him and then um this is me just
remembering by the way it might not be fully accurate just
me trying to remember this game that played like almost it
was 10 plus yeah 10 plus years ago and so and then like the
dragonflies family um found the drag the egg and raised them
as his own even though they're all dragon you know because
they had dragons and dragonfly it's almost the same thing
and it sparks is buff as fuck and he could talk now um yeah
so he's buff as fuck now And then he's he can talk so and
then he's voiced by oh, it was so funny He's like voiced by
who was he voiced by?
I think that was when I found out He was voiced by Oh, he
was voiced the first David Spade.
He was voiced by David Spade The first one yeah, because the
first one that was stars.
It was a star-studded cast like Elijah wood was a was Spyro,
and then David Spade was Sparks.
We don't know who David Spade.
He is a comedian that you will see in, like, who was Adam
Sadler movies, right?
He's, oh, he's, he was, he's basically Cusco, an Emperor's
New Groove.
He's Cusco.
And he's also, he's basically like, Adam Sadler's plus one,
one of his plus ones when, yeah, so Sparks was started being
voiced by David Spade, everything it it was weird it was a
weird game and then and then so like you know and then so
but then the evil wizard controls this evil dragon and then
because she she basically and then you find out she's a
woman so she has like this other big i don't know i don't
remember why she's like an evil bigger form so she's like
this giant big form evil dragon and then um and then you
know kills the wizard and then frees the evil dragon so
she's not evil anymore and then you find out she's a woman
like she she's a female dragon and she turns into spiral
size I don't remember why she was big and now small um yeah
send like her and then you find out she's like she's cinder
and she has like PTSD when she was evil um and then I don't
know then then they started dating and I guess I don't know
they had they fucking had kids I don't remember after that I
know like and then in the newer games after the first game
you play co-op you play co-op and then also be the now
reformed not evil female dragon
yeah she was oh yeah she was wintered soldier cinder was
wintered soldiered yeah because she was wearing this giant
this collar that made her big and evil and then spiral saved
her and now she's she's conveniently spiral sized now and
also the same age as him wow style needed a girlfriend there
always there needs to be a female spiral um very convenient
uh yes so so that was the legend of spiral so that's why i'm
really worried because i'm really worried that they won't be
able to make a good spiral game because no gaming developer
has been able to make a good spiral game after insomniac
because insomniac perfected the formula for spiral and toys
for life only just remade the game like everything was the
same i played it it was just higher graphics um it was just
like i i am cautiously optimistic because i saw the gameplay
for it or toys for yeah i saw toys for bob i saw the
gameplay of it and i was it reminded me of uh what was it
called i don't i know i said it once It reminded me of Enter
the Dragonfly.
And I'm scared.
Because our toys were Bob.
Yeah.
I played the remake.
And I played the original so many times.
I never played one.
I hated one.
I didn't play one.
Even the remake.
And it makes me worried.
Because when I saw the gameplay for it.
it reminded me of enter the dragonfly and that fucking
fucking sucked that game um was so bad and that's what it
reminded me the level design for it just gave me like fight
or flight but most it would give me flight or flight
I'm not going to be like, oh, I'm going to be hesitant for
it just because it doesn't, it doesn't feel like the
original trilogy.
Because like I said, I played the original trilogy.
I played the old version so many times.
So it was like cemented in my brain of how it played.
And it was literally like the same.
It was just newer graphics.
Newer graphics, better AI for the enemies.
But everything was true to the original.
They didn't add anything new.
There was no new like.
There was no, like, new things they added for it.
Not going to lie.
Everything felt the same.
Just newer graphics.
So we'll see how it goes.
We'll see how it goes.
Anyway, that was my Spyro TED Talk.
I fucking love Spyro.
You don't understand.
I replayed when I was growing up.
I replayed the original, like, Spyro 2 and 3 so many times
growing up.
Like, I would replay the game a lot.
And I would replay the game.
game so many times growing up and then um and also like i
played every spiral game every console spiral game because
fuck the gba stuff bro like that was just i all the gba shit
was just cash grabs like fuck the gbas they're they're not
even real games like oh some gbas are some gbas are but the
spy there were not real anyway he said there were some good
ones but the one not for spyro not for spyro i remember i i
don't remember i just remember looking at us like bro now
let me introduce you to some of my esteemed colleagues
there's some good ones but like spyro just did not fit the
aesthetic of the gpa game
oh did you hear well that is an unfortunate name i hope it's
not as pronounced as i think it is i hope
cheap rubbish what now is worse to in the grave as they say
look at the bloody airships we're not here for you Do you
hear about how like we're getting closer to the Omnic?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I didn't pause that.
People were saying this game was a huge larper because the
lady was, because it's like ye old British times, you know?
It was during the industrial era.
And people at back then, the British back then did not have
the middle finger.
So, yeah.
So they're like, like people do not use the middle finger
the the v so if they're like why is she doing the middle
finger yeah people were like that's a larp britton had
invented yeah larping as britton this is what time traveling
yeah but she looks like she's from greetings i am the
miracle it would make more sense if it was a v if you have
the Rockworks City.
They didn't have robots.
Look.
Priorities here.
There's levels to it.
Not because of the robots.
But she didn't use the middle finger.
Well, I certainly don't expect any trouble from some of
Avalon's most disposable citizens.
If they're going to use the British axe, it yeah thank you
for the tier one sub thank you thank you i mean it's it's
team punk 25 years back in time this place on this day is
right but yeah the omnic uprising is we're slowly getting
closer have you seen that video of that robot kicking a
child in the stomach and then everyone was just like like
whoo yeah she was doing like a kung fu demonstration or
something I don't remember it was like it's not a kung fu
what the fuck oh that reminds me of the Resident Evil dog
but like it was doing some performance and then what the and
then and then it like kicked the child child in the stomach
and nobody like what no no one helped the child nothing's
ever given to folk like us especially not the future no it
was like it just chose a random child there were like other
kids lined up watching and then it just it just slowly
walked towards the other child and it kicked it We're
getting closer to the Omnic Uprising.
Clockwork Revolution.
Coming in due time.
Oh, that's clever.
Yeah, it was like a parade or something.
Clockwork Revolution is an original experience full of
intriguing characters and incredible world building.
The first...
They believe in this game a lot.
Oh, it's because it's a console exclusive.
That's why.
Oh, it's the name Mapudi?
That's a good name.
This is a milestone year for us as we celebrate 25 years
with you.
And we're excited about our lineup of iconic games.
We're breaking forts of Horizon 6.
So it's been like 20 plus generations of booty.
Built from the ground up.
The extraordinary world of fable full of choice and
consequences.
Incredible games from our partners.
It's Sega, 4A Games, Koei Tecmo, and more.
It's a generational booty.
The players can look forward to two upcoming exclusives,
Gears of War E-Day in 2026, and Clockwork Revolution in
2027.
In a moment, we'll dive into Gears of War E-Day.
But before we do, one franchise that has been with us from
the beginning is Call of Duty.
Mark, thank you for the tier one sub, thinking, thank you.
With a new modern warfare later this year and a movie on the
way.
A movie?
Yeah, I forgot about that.
Activision gave us a glimpse of the story and gameplay.
Today, they are back with a first look at DMZ.
Reimagined in a way...
Oh, is this a movie trailer?
Activision, let's go.
No, it's gameplay?
Oh, I thought it was because you're talking about the
trailer.
In-game footage with screen images added.
Nice.
Oh, are we like...
What?
Oh, we're in that war now.
I was going to say, oh, I wonder which dictator that one is.
We're...
Wow.
I wonder who these people are parenting.
Entering the DMC Oh my god Wait Okay You know how like I'm
sorry I'm pausing a lot You know how like we were talking
about how Some of the girls wanted to do a A spa day in
Korea Well
So you know how like We had staff with us Like each of us
had a staff with us like you know and so my staff member was
like hey because i was like i don't really want to go to the
spa but they never didn't get their spa so like it was
supposed to be like the first like what were you gonna do
when they go to the spa and then my staff member was like do
you want to go to the border of the border do you think we
could request that and i was like i do not want to get kids
i don't i'm like not taking my i was like that's cool at
first i was like wait that's cool like while the girls get
the slotted and go to the border get the door of the border
Like, I thought about it, I was like, that would be
interesting.
That would be a story, you know?
That would have been a story, you know?
Because they do do tours of it.
It's just obviously not at the exact border.
They do do tours of it.
And then if you're in, I don't even China, you can actually
go to North Korea.
Like, you can, you can, if you're in China, you can go to
North Korea as a tour.
I was like, I thought about it.
It actually thought I crossed my head.
And then I was like, there is a percentage that you could
get kidnapped.
And I didn't, I don't know.
I didn't trust my luck at that time.
I was like, I was like, the fact that there is a percentage,
like it is a percentage.
It's not a non-zero percent chance.
It's not, it's not.
not a non-zero percent chance that's the part so so I was
like I don't think we let it ride I don't I don't think we
let it ride so I was like I was like we're not gonna ask
we're I mean we didn't ask yeah yeah like it crossed my head
because I thought about it because I was like that would be
you know like because they do do the tours for it i know
they do i've read about it before where like it's not like
obviously it's not next to the border it's just like you
it's like the near the patrol area um and uh uh it's like
near the patrolling area so it's like safe but then like
it's on non-zero percent chance like you know like it's not
unfortunately it's not a zero I was just like, I'm not
risking that.
Because for those who don't know, it's a ceasefire.
It's not, it's a ceasefire.
So it's not like, so like, you know, you know what a
ceasefire is, right?
It's a temporary pause.
It can, it can unpause whenever and we don't know when.
So, so I'm just thinking like we don't know when it will
unpause.
pause.
So, yeah.
So, I was just like, I was like, let's not ask about that.
Let's not.
I don't want to trigger any of it.
Yeah, I'm going to head downstairs real quick.
See if there's any weapons or gear laying around.
Anyway, back to caught.
I mean, they're in North Korea right now, apparently.
That's Like, have a, they're like, what wars should we do?
This is a war that hasn't even technically ended yet.
Like, that's crazy.
Damn, he's down.
Yeah, because usually, a lot of the Call of Duty games, it's
like, old wars, you know?
Yeah.
So...
found that HPT on you so like I don't know if any of the
other ones are there's a future one I remember like yeah our
few it's usually old wars or future wars so this is I don't
know this is a newer direction but I've always I've seen a
lot I mean there's one where like what if like you know
Hitler won and there's one of them for that too I mean
that's just what's it called that's
But this is a current situation, the current situation,
yeah.
That is my aim.
Oh my god, the recoil is crazy.
This recoil is insane.
Oh, what's up?
He is not shooting anything.
Did he close the elevator on his friend?
No, he's behind him.
Okay, it looked like he closed the elevator.
Oh shit, well he's dead.
It didn't matter.
Oh wait, he's alive.
Oh hey, look, there's makeup.
Bro baited his teammate.
Yeah.
This is interesting.
It is very interesting.
Oh shit!
I think it is taking place in South.
Is it?
Oh, is this a future scenario where like, if there was no
ceasefire because someone won?
Is that the case?
Is that the scenario?
I'm inside Ah I see
Yeah, it was it's like Yeah I think
I think the ceasefire stopped in this scenario
Oh fuck what the helicopters got Well someone's not getting
on that chopper I mean, sick-ass helmet, I guess.
What is this biker helmet gonna do for you?
Oh, there's ghosts.
To be cool.
Alright, DM Call of Duty Modern Warfare.
What does that even say?
Is that... Oh, wait.
That looks like a...
Isn't it actually an extraction shooter?
Oh my god.
Really?
Oh, is that four?
Oh.
Alright.
I didn't realize.
I never played it.
I played the Battle of Royale.
Welcome to the coalition here in Vancouver, British
Columbia, Canada.
Home of Gears of War.
Wait, that's the home of Gears of War?
It instantly redefined the genre.
And now in 2020, how are they paying the rent of another
rare moment?
I didn't know that.
Here's the word Canadian?
And lay the foundation for where Gears is going next.
Yeah.
To get there, we're taking it all the way back to the day
the world changed.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I haven't really released a new game
in a while.
How are they paying?
Oh, that's true of Microsoft money.
It's a day of unimaginable loss that sits at the heart of
our universe.
And today, for the first time, we're ready to take you
inside the studio and show you all the ways to play with our
new movements, weapons, and modes that will make Idae the
most brutally satisfying gears yet.
I'm sorry, but John Imaggio, before we talk about what this
game is, I think it's important to show why we chose Idae.
When we started this project, we were moving to Unreal
Engine 5.
There's a new foundation with a blank slate.
cases right yeah it makes gears so special to us and to our
fans we realize that all of the things that make this world
is this section really long is it worth it brutality that
melancholy beauty over the top spectacle they're all
perfectly set it's just this it's just gears
the moment the locus ripped through the ground and changed
the history of sarah forever where did they say it ended
what when did they say it ended what was even though i don't
remember what it's marcus facing down the locust defiantly
they did it they ended with god we said this is the
emotional core of gifts this is the tone and feeling that we
wanted to build our next game around this is our most
ambitious game yet eday is a story we haven't been able to
tell before it was a five it was a 10 second countdown we
finally have the tools to reimagine the serious world at a
new it's just wait it's just it's just gears locations in
and around the ward it's just it's just y'all it's just gear
and the story I think we can all relate to thanks for
pushing through couldn't have done it alone they didn't even
give up like a warning that this was the last one in the
same year as the 20th anniversary of Gears the
quarter-century anniversary of Xbox it's almost like a
homecoming we're gonna watch that next time I've been live
for I have two hours of sleep and I've been live for six
hours it's an incredible honor and one that we want to make
sure that we do right this one it's 30 minutes of dev talk
about Gears guys
oh my god mr booty said con was announced last announcement
who would pay attention to that when his last name is booty
like everyone will be no one was paying attention to that
guys when it was live he was like his last name is booty but
true we rally around a simple phrase never fight alone it
guides how we build our our world it's how we work as a team
and the commitment we make to you our fans everything comes
back to that important idea of sharing life's experiences
the highs and lows together yeah the best expression of
never fight alone that we've ever made whether you'll be
picking up a lancer for the first time ever or you're as
battle-hardened as marcus phoenix there's always a place for
you in the gear squad when emergence begins on october 6th
over six.
Okay.
I mean, that's pretty close, actually.
I have really bad jet lag.
I want to tank it, and then so I can't wake up.
I'm actually really tired now.
I feel like I can retake it if I sleep now.
Alright.
Well, now it's officially over.
There we go.
That's like a summary of everything.
I know why you're here.
She does.
all right this one i i'm gonna have fun with the dokey stock
beans here all right we're gonna call it here guys now you
ready to get to it thank you all for coming hope you guys
enjoyed today's uh stream sorry we didn't watch all the
showcases additional four more hours and i don't think i
don't think i want to stream for 10 hours today i am not
awake i've been running on on my on my coffee yeah
especially when summer game fest was two like minimum two
hours a lot i did sort of fix my sleep schedule maybe um but
i hope you guys had a lot of fun watching this with me also
with the sponsor today, huge shout out again to Sega for
sponsoring the stream today with Hatsune Miku, Colorful
Sage.
I hope we can do more stuff in the future with them.
So huge shout out to them.
And I hope they liked my sponsor stream.
And I hope you guys liked hanging out with me too and
playing the video games today.
Now, thank you for But anyway, I hope you guys had a fun
time watching me today.
I hope you guys have had a fun time watching the showcase.
Well, one of the showcase.
But on Thursday, we will.
On Thursday, we will watch the rest of them because I have
no other days free.
Thursday is the only day that's free for me to continue
watching stuff.
say well it's going to be on twitch still um what else but
anyway uh if you want to support the stream you want to
support uh i want to support the stream you want to support
me i want uh please feel free to check me on youtube that's
where my main channel is you want to support the no one on
my stream on twitch please follow me on twitter because
that's where i post announcements on twitch streams um if
you want to what else what else what else uh um i don't
remember the stuff i say for twitch outros i'm so tired guys
i'm so tired i don't know i know i have a bunch of commands
you guys can autopilot this for me i you guys can help me
take over um but thank you i'm so sorry for the subs the
bitties the those i really appreciate i'm sorry i didn't
thank all the the subs today um i had i didn't pull up the
thing for it because i was getting um i got i usually don't
want to read too many like sub stuff when i'm during the
sponsor because i'm worried that i would be like reading it
too much so i would be reading too much and then i like uh
but that went over time and so because i was like oh no i
don't want to like distract not distract not the right word
not like um make sure i showcase everything on for the
sponsor um so i was just worried that uh uh I wouldn't be
able to show everything from a sponsor, so I was, like,
trying to lock in.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody stay hydrated, pause the
check, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
Instead of for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys later.
I'm going to pass out.
Bye!
Bye, bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.